हेलो
एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड इवनिंग
टू
ऑल ओके नमस्ते तो सबसे पहले मुझे बताइए
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है
ओके थैंक यू हेलो अब्दुल एंड नमस्ते ओके
शुभम ओके साहिल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग आदित्य सिंह वेरी गुड
इवनिंग जगत गुरु जी नमस्कार
ओके नमस्ते
नमस्ते कैसे हो आप
सब आज हम क्या सीखेंगे बहुत ही अच्छा सवाल
है अभी तक तो हम जो कुछ सीख रहे हैं वह भी
काफी कुछ सीखा हमने और अभी तक जितना भी
हमने सीखा वह सब कुछ नेक्स प्रज एस्केलेशन
का पार्ट है बट आज हम सीखने वाले हैं नक्
बलेज एस्केलेशन में फोकस करेंगे खास कर की
कुछ नेक्स्ट क्लास में कि कुछ टेक्निक्स
होती है जो आपको डेफिनेटली चेक करनी चाहिए
ड्यूरिंग लिनिक्स पन टेस्टिंग जब आपकी
मशीन नक् हो तो उस टाइम पे आपको ध्यान में
रखनी चाहिए
तो सबसे पहले एक छोटा सा टॉपिक होगा आज की
क्लास में कि मैंने बताया था लास्ट क्लास
में कि नॉन इंटरेक्ट सेल से इंटरेक्ट सेल
में हम कैसे अपग्रेड करेंगे जस्ट 10 टू 15
मिनट देन उसके बाद हम लिनक्स पज एलेशन में
से एक पार्ट हम हमेशा सीखते आए हैं बट कुछ
और टेक्निक्स है जो बेसिक लेवल पर आपको
पता होने चाहिए कि अगर आपको नक् के अंदर
सेल एक्सेस चाहिए रूट सेल एक्सेस चाहिए
आफ्टर एक्सप्लोइटेशन देन कौन-कौन से
रास्ते हैं कौन-कौन से तरीके हैं ज मैं या
कौन-कौन सी चेक ऑफ लिस्ट है एज ए बिगनर
लेवल पर मैं फॉलो कर सकता हूं तो आज वो हम
सीखने वाले हैं
थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं दो से तीन मिनट
का उसके बाद हम कंटिन्यू करेंगे सेशन को
और डोंट मिस द क्लास क्योंकि आज से हम
लिनक्स एक्सले पर ज्यादा फोकस करेंगे जो
नेक्स्ट क्लास होगी वह भी लिनक्स
प्रिविलेज एलेशन की होगी उससे नेक्स्ट भी
जो होगी वह भी लिनक्स प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
की होगी तो अभी नक् प्र टोटली फोकस करेंगे
पर्टिकुलर टॉपिक प
य आ टेक टू कहां पर आपने मैसेज किया
था तो आज यह बताइए सबसे पहले कि कितने नए
स्टूडेंट्स हैं जो फर्स्ट टाइम क्लास में
आए हैं
जिनका आज फर्स्ट डे है
ओके आपका फर्स्ट डे है तो यूडी टेक आपको
क्या करना है जो अभी लिंक भेजा गया आपको ट
चैनल का उसको जवाइन कर लीजिए और आई
रिक्वेस्ट की जितने भी स्टूडेंट्स है
जिन्होंने अभी तक डेफ अकेडमी के
य चैनल को जवाइन नहीं किया है लेटेस्ट
अपडेट के लिए तो प्लीज उनको जवाइन कीजिए
वहां पर आपको लेटेस्ट अपडेट मिलते रहेंगे
ओके कौन से टूल्स मिलेंगे मैं आपको मैनुअल
टेक्निक्स बताऊंगा और एक टूल्स है काफी
फेमस और पॉपुलर टूल्स है जिसके बारे में
आपने सुना भी होगा लिन पीज तो उसके बारे
में भी मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन करूंगा बट एंड
एंड में एक्सप्लेन करूंगा स्टार्टिंग में
आपको मैनुअल टेक्निक सिखाऊंगा जो कुछ
कमांड्स होती है जिनके थ्रू आप चेक कर
सकते हो उसके बाद ट्राई टू एक्सप्लोइट द
मशीन
देन एट द एंड यू विल सी लिन पीज
ओके अगर आपके पास पीसी नहीं है
तो आप गलत जगह पर हो विदाउट पीसी आप साइबर
सिक्योरिटी नहीं सीख सकते ट्रुथ है कड़वा
है पर सच
है पाइथन वाली स्क्रिप्ट अब्दुल लिंक देन
पर मैंने शेयर की हुई है अगर आपने मेरी
पोस्ट देखी होगी मैंने पाइथन वाली
स्क्रिप्ट पूरा सोर्स कोड उसका मैंने लिंक
दिन पे पोस्ट किया हुआ
है यस बिल्कुल
डेफिनेटली यू क्लियर योर ईजी पीटी आदित्य
सिंह आई गारंटी यू आप कर सकते हो क्योंकि
जो भी टेक्निक्स और टैक्टिक्स मैं आपको
बता रहा हूं और आपने डेडिकेट फॉलो किया है
सारी कमांड्स को आपने नोट डाउन कर लिया है
और आपको पता है कि कौन सी कमांड का क्या
रिजल्ट आता है और कौन सी चीज पर मुझे क्या
करना है तो डेफिनेटली य क्लियर यो जीजी
पीटी वेरी
इजली तो तब तक के लिए एक बार मैं मशीन पर
चलता हूं और जहां पर लास्ट टेप में थे हम
वहां पर चलते हैं एक बार अभी तक जो मशीन
उसको लॉगिन कर लेते हैं देन उसके बाद हम
कंटिन्यू करेंगे
यूडी टेक आप एक काम कीजिए आप स्टार्टिंग
से तो देखिए देखिए लेकिन अभी की प्रेजेंट
क्लास को मिस मत कीजिए यहां पर भी आपको
कुछ ना कुछ सीखने को
मिलेगा तो अभी एक काम करते हैं हम एक बार
रिवर्स सेल ले लेते हैं और जिस सिचुएशन
में थे हम उस सिचुएशन में जाके फिर से
स्टक हो जाते हैं तो रिवर्स सेल के लिए एक
बार हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा यह रहा टूथ 4
एंड
रिफ्रेश एंड वी सक्सेसफुली गेट अवर सेल तो
यहीं पर थे हम सबको पता है हमने यहां पर
क्या था हु एम
आई डेमन एंड देन सीडी
होम एंड देन सीडी
रोबोट नो नो नो नो नो एलस देन सीडी
रोबोट ट इज एंड एलस ज आर द टू फाइल्स एंड
कैट जब हमने
किया
पासवर्ड डॉट रो हाइन
md5 हिट एंटर यहां पर थी हमें हमें रोबोट
और उसका पासवर्ड हमारे पास था
ओके तो एक दिन गोकुल हम क्या
करेंगे जैसे ही नक् पलेज एस्केलेशन या नक्
का जो पार्ट खत्म हो जाएगा एक दिन हम
डेडिकेट ओपन सेशन रखेंगे जिसमें आप मुझसे
कोई भी बात पूछ सकते हो रिलेटेड टू द जो व
जहां तक हमने पढ़ा या रिलेटेड टू योर
करियर आप मुझसे पूछ सकते हो मैं वहां पर
आपको डेफिनेटली गाइड करूंगा लेकिन वहां पर
मुझे स्पैम करने वाले बंदे नहीं चाहिए कि
वहां पर सर यह है वो है मुझे वो नहीं
चाहिए जस्ट डेडीकेटेडली बंदे चाहिए जिनको
सच में जननली गाइड की रिक्वायरमेंट है
और वो जवाइन करें और मुझसे बात कर सकते
हैं मैं आपका जवाब दूंगा
या आई विल कवर परसिस्टेंस पिटिंग एट आई
विल आल्सो कवर बेसिक लेवल तो आज जो फेस
मैं आपको बताता हूं आज ही आज आप आपको पता
चल
जाएगा तो पीवीटी एटीडी
सुशांत ओके तोके सचि
बात ऐसी है आप मेरे को लिंकडन पर टैग
कीजिए और लिंकन पर मैसेज कीजिए रिक्वेस्ट
भेजिए एंड डेफिनेटली आई विल गाइड
य तोके अभी हम क्लास को स्टार्ट करें फिर
टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करेंगे हम ओके तो लास्ट
मैंने आपको बताया था जैसे ही मैं स्विच
यूजर किया हमने रोबोट इसका पासवर्ड हमारे
पास है तो मस्ट बी रन फ्रॉम ए टर्मिनल ओके
यहां पर बोला गया कि आपको टर्मिनल से रन
करना है बेसिकली आपको पता है एक डेमन डेमन
प्रोसेस है मतलब कि जब आप रिमोट कोड
एग्जीक्यूशन परफॉर्म करते हो तो रिमोट कोड
कोड एग्जीक्यूशन के दौरान 99 परज में आपको
क्या करता है जो आरसी ही है आपको जो वीक
प्रोसेस है उसके थ्रू एक्सेस प्रोवाइड
करता है जहां पर आपको नॉन इंटरेक्ट सेल
मिलता है और इससे पहले भी आपके सामने कई
प्रॉब्लम आए तो हम सबसे पहले स्लाइड पर
चलते हैं देन उसके बाद हम कंटिन्यू करते
हैं बाद में चैट में आएंगे लास्ट में
मुझसे पूछ लेना तो गो टू अवर स्लाइड एंड
देखो तो आज सबसे पहले हम बात करने वाले एक
सबसे इंपोर्टेंट चैप्टर है ओके चैप्टर
नंबर पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन सबको पता है
जिसमें हम स्टेप नंबर थ्री की बात करने
वाले हैं अपग्रेडिंग सेल्स कि अगर हमारे
पास नॉन इंटरेक्ट सेल है तो उसको इंटरेक्ट
सेल में हमें अपग्रेड कैसे करना है तो
आपको पता है कि जो पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन
मेथोड जीी है जिसमें आपको पता है टोटल देर
आर एट स्टेप्स जिसमें लोकल एन्यूमरेशन ऑन
लिनक्स हम परफॉर्म कर चुके हैं देन उसके
बाद ट्रांसफरिंग ऑफ फाइल्स उसका जब टॉपिक
आएगा मैं यह भी आपको सिखा दूंगा लेकिन जो
अपग्रेडिंग सेल्स वाला जो स्टेप थ्री है
वो आज हम परफॉर्म करने वाले हैं स्टेप फोर
की शुरुआत करने वाले हैं फिर हमारे बच
जाएंगे स्टेप फाइव स्टेप सिक्स स्टेप सेवन
और स्टेप एट धीरे-धीरे इनको भी हम कवर
करेंगे तो आज हम स्टेप थ्री और फोर की
शुरुआत करने वाले हैं तो सबसे पहले हम बात
करते हैं अपग्रेडिंग सेल अगर आपका जो सेल
है वो नॉन इंटरेक्ट सेल है तो आप उसको
अपग्रेड कैसे कर सकते हो कुछ टेक्निक्स
होती हैं जिनके थ्रू आप कर सकते हो तो अभी
अभी आपको पता है कि नॉन इंटरेक्ट सेल है
अभी तक हमने जो भी कुछ किया अपनी
मशीन को एक्सप्लोइट करते हो एक्सप्लोइट
करने के बाद आपको इस तरीके कोई टर्मिनल
दिखता है जैसे कि मैंने यहां पर क्या किया
कि जो हमारा एमएसएफ कंसोल था तो एमएसएफ
कंसोल के थ्रू हमने किसी मशीन को
एक्सप्लोइट किया टारगेट मशीन को और वहां
पर हमें रिस्पांस जो मिला वहां पर हमें जो
रिवर्स सेल मिला व मिटर पटर रिवर्स सेल
मिला तो यह सिचुएशन आपके सामने पहले
प्रीवियस जो सीटीएफ हमने परफॉर्म किए थी
उसमें आपके सामने य आ चुकी है सबके सामने
आई है सिचुएशन या नहीं आई है
बताइए सबके सामने सिचुएशन आई है
ना हा तो यह सिचुएशन आई तो सिचुएशन में आप
क्या करते थे डायरेक्टली स्ल बन स्ल बैस
और आई का यूज करते थे दिस इज गुड अप्रोच
बट यहां पर सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट पॉइंट यह है
जो आपको हमेशा ध्यान रखना है किय अप्रोच
हमेशा काम नहीं करेगी क्यों नहीं काम
करेगी क्योंकि लिनक्स सिस्टम डज नॉट नीड
टू हैव बैस इंस्टॉल जरूरी नहीं है कि
आपको जो टैक्टिक्स है उनको बदलना पड़ेगा
थोड़ी दूसरी जो कमांड्स है उनका यूज करना
पड़ेगा जो आपके पास अवेलेबल है तो व
कौन-कौन सी कमांड्स है या कौन-कौन सी
टैक्टिक्स है मैं आपको शो करने वाला हूं
तो वो शो करने के लिए हम यूज करेंगे सबसे
पहले देखो यह वो कमांड है आप सबसे पहले
एकको डॉलर जीरो यूज करोगे जिसका मतलब आप
करंट सेल टाइप चेक कर सकते हो हु एम आई
आपको पता है कि यूजर की आइडेंटिटी क्या है
फिर आपको चेक करना है कि क्या इस मशीन में
जो है जिस मशीन आपको सेल एक्सेस मिला है
उसमें
python's इंस्टॉल है या नहीं है पर्ल
इंस्टॉल है या नहीं है नेट कट अवेलेबल है
या नहीं है शो कट अवेलेबल है या नहीं है
या स्क्रिप्ट अवेलेबल है या नहीं है ये
सारी चीजें आपको चेक करनी है या तो एक ही
कमांड में आप लिख सकते हो विच python3
स्पेस बैस स्पेस पर्ल स्पेस एनसी स्पेस
सोकेट स्पेस स्क्रिप्ट या वन बाय वन बाई
आप चेक कर सकते हो या इनकी बजाय एक फाइल
और होती है जहां पर आप यह भी चेक कर सकते
हो कौन-कौन से सेल मेरी मशीन में अवेलेबल
है वो भी मैं आपको बताता हूं देन उसके बाद
आप क्या कर सकते हो इस इंफॉर्मेशन के आधार
पर आप अपनी जो मेथड्स हैं कुछ प्री
डिफाइंड मेथड्स हैं आप उनका यूज करोगे
अपने सेल को अपग्रेड करने के लिए अब जरूरी
नहीं है कि वह सारे मेथड्स आपके काम करें
इनमें से कौन सा मेथड आपके केस में काम
करेगा और कौन सा मेथड काम नहीं करेगा यह
किसी को नहीं पता क्योंकि मशीन को किस
तरीके से डिजाइन किया गया है किस तरीके से
उसकी हार्ड निंग की गई है यह डिपेंड करता
है आपके एडम ट के ऊपर तो अभी हम सबसे पहले
क्या परफॉर्म करने वाले हैं चलो गो टू अवर
टैब एंड दिस इज अवर मशीन देन देन या
ओके चलो यह हमारी मशीन है तो हम क्या करने
वाले सबसे पहले जूम और भी ज्यादा जूम करने
की जरूरत है सबको क्लियर दिखाई दे रहा है
ओके तो अभी हम क्या करते हैं सबसे पहले हम
चेक करते हैं हु एम आई आपको पता है हम
डायमन है इसको हमें चेक करने की जरूरत
नहीं होती हम करते हैं एकको और डॉलर जीरो
जैसे डॉलर जीरो हम करेंगे आपको पता चल गया
कौन सा मशीन कौन सा सेल हम यूज कर रहे अभी
स्ल बिन स्ल एस एक कमांड होती है हम कैट
कमांड का यूज करते कैट स्ल ईटीसी स्ल कौ
सी कमांड होती है सेल ये एक फाइल होती है
ओके सेल होती है या ओके वेट वेट
वेट ओके ओके ओके ओके एक ये कमांड होती है
कौन सी सीटीसी आई डोंट रिमेंबर नाउ वेट
सेकंड ओके ओके ओके सेल्स होती है तो कैट
स्ल टीसी
स्लश सेल्स ओके नाउ हिट एंटर तो यहां पर
आप चेक कर सकते हो कि आपकी मशीन में
कौन-कौन से सेल्स आर अवेलेबल कौन-कौन से
सेल आपके मशीन में अवेलेबल है य कितना
छोटा
यार ओके तो यहां पर आप चेक कर सकते हो
देखिए आपकी मशीन में जो सेल अवेलेबल स्ल
बिन स्ल बैस स्ल डस बैस आर बैस बिन
स्क्रीन बट प्रॉब्लम इज दैट कि इस मशीन
में बाकी सेल काम नहीं कर र अगर आप यह
टेक्निक यूज कर स्ल बिन स्ल बस आई तो यह
काम नहीं करने वाला अगर आपको यकीन नहीं
होता तो स्लैश बिन अभी तक हमने क्या था
स्लैश बिन स्लश बैस कई बार यह काम कर देता
लेकिन अभी इधर काम नहीं करने वाला इन अभी
देखिए अभी यहां पर अभी मैं इसको जूम कर
लेता हूं अभी हम इसको जूम करेंगे तो यह
रहा ना अरे यार यह तो पूरा ही प्रॉब्लम
इसकी
है हां अभी सही रहेगा
नाउ ये रहा सबको क्लियर दिखाई दे रहा है
तो यहां पर अभी हम चलते हैं स्क्रोल डाउन
तो अभी आपने देखा होगा कि कैन नॉट सेट
टर्मिनल प्रोसेस ग्रुप एंड नो जॉब कंट्रोल
इन द सेल तो वी कांट डू एनीथिंग तो अभी हम
क्या करते हैं अग अदर ऑप्शन हमारे पास है
हम चेक करेंगे हु एम आई मतलब
वि चच और हम चेक करते हैं
पाइथन पाइथन इससे हम चेक कर सकते हो क्या
पाइथन इस मशीन में इंस्टॉल है इस मशीन में
क्या है पाइथन इंस्टॉल्ड है जब पाइथन
इंस्टॉल है तो हमारे पास वैसे तो हम बाकी
भी चेक करते हैं चलो कि चच
[संगीत]
अ चच और बेस यह भी इंस्टॉल है आपको पता है
स्लश बिन बेस हम विच पर्ल पर्ल भी हम चेक
करते हैं कि ये भी इंस्टॉल है क्योंकि
सबके पास की कुछ कमांड होती है जिनकी
हेल्प से क्या कर सकते हो सेल एक्सेस ले
सकते हो ये भी भी अवेलेबल है विच उसके बाद
एनसी नेट कट ये भी अवेलेबल है और विच
कमांड का यूज करके आप शो कट चेक करोगे
सोकेट ओके इट इज नॉट अवेलेबल यह अवेलेबल
नहीं है उसके बाद चच
स्क्रिप्ट यह कमांड अवेलेबल है या ओके
स्क्रिप्ट नाम से भी आपकी कमांड अवेलेबल
है अभी मैं क्या करने वाला हूं मुझे क्या
चाहिए इंटरेक्ट सेल चाहिए तो इंटरेक्ट सेल
के मैं क्या करने वाला हूं एक पाइथन कमांड
है ये रही इस कमांड को हम यूज करेंगे
क्योंकि एक सूडो टर्मिनल वाली कमांड है
कॉपी किया हमने और डायरेक्टली हम क्या
करेंगे अभी पेस्ट कर देंगे इधर सिलेक्शन
और सक्सेसफुली हिट एंटर और हमें क्या हुआ
सेल मिल गया कि पाइथन 3 सी इंपोर्ट पीटीवा
पीटीवा ड स्पन हमें एक टर्मिनल मिल गया
कैसे अभी हम देखेंगे तो अभी हम स्विच कर
सकते हैं आगे हम चेक करेंगे
एक एक डॉलर जी तो अभी हमें सक्सेसफुली एक
इंटरेक्ट सेल मिल गया है और अगर हम स्विच
करना चाहे स्विच हम क्या करेंगे स्विच
रोबोट अभी हमारी कमांड हम रन करेंगे स्विच
रोबोट अभी पासवर्ड मांगा इसने तो हमारे
पास पासवर्ड कहां पर है यह रहा md5 को
हमने डिक्रिप्ट किया था तो हमें पासवर्ड
क्या मिला था ए से लेकर जड तक सारे
अल्फाबेट्स में हमें यह पासवर्ड मिल गया
था कॉपी किया देन उसके बाद गो टू एंड यहां
पर हम पेस्ट कर देंगे पासवर्ड को पेस्ट
क्लिपबोर्ड और हिट एंटर तो हमने
सक्सेसफुली जो रोबोट यूजर था उसके अकाउंट
में हमने लॉग इन कर लिया तो हु एम आई अब
हम चेक करेंगे तो वी आर रोबोट अभी हम एक
प्रोसेस नहीं हम एक यूजर हैं तो अभी आप
चाहो तो यह जो चीट शट है यहां पर जो अदर
कमांड्स है यहां पर जो जनरल मेथड्स
अपग्रेड करने के वह आपके सामने य पर
अवेलेबल से आपको हमारे
जो ऐप है वहां पर आपको देखने को जो ₹ का
जो आपने बाय किया है नोट्स के अंदर वो
जल्दी एक दो दिन में अपडेट हो जाएगा तो
वहां पर ये आपको सारी देखने को मिल जाएगी
आगे और भी है जैसे कि ये रहा आप टीटी वाई
जैसे कि सॉकेट की हेल्प से भी क्या कर
सकते हो अगर आपकी मशीन में इंस्टॉल है तो
इस तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो सेल
एक्सेस ले सकते हो एनसी की हेल्प से भी आप
सेल एक्सेस ले सकते हो तो दज आर द सम चीट
शीट आर अवेलेबल फॉर अपग्रेडिंग नॉन
इंटरेक्ट सेल टू इंटरेक्ट इव सेल जस्ट
छोटा सा टॉपिक था अभी हमें एक्सेस मिल गया
क्योंकि पाइथन इंस्टॉल थी जब पाइथन
इंस्टॉल थी तो अभी मैं क्या करूंगा अभी
मुझे क्या करना है सीडी होम डायरेक्टरी के
अंदर जाना है सीडी होम हिट एंटर और एलस
किया तो यहां पर रोबोट है तो सीडी रोबोट
हिट एंड एलस दज आर टू फाइल्स तो यहां पर
हमें एक
की
हाइन टू हाइन ऑफ
हाइन डटी एक्सटी डटी एक्सटी हिट एंटर तो
यह हमारा सेकंड फ्लैग मिल गया लेकिन
अल्टीमेट जो हमारा गोल है जो एंड गोल है
वो क्या है कंप्लीट रूट एक्सेस चाहिए हमें
अभी हमें रूट एक्सेस चाहिए तो हमें क्या
करना पड़ेगा यहां पर फर्द अभी पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन टेक्निक का यूज करना पड़ेगा
तो आप य नेम हान ए चेक करोगे तो दिस इज द
[संगीत]
करते हैं आपको पता है कि सुडो लेजस के
थ्रू हमने अभी तक जितनी भी मशीन को
कंप्रोमाइज किया है जितनी भी मशीन को हमने
रूट एक्सेस लिया है वह थ्रू सुडो हान एल
हमने चेक किया वहां पर हमें जो परमिशन
मिली एज ए रूट यूजर या जो सुडो परमिशन थी
उस परमिशन के बेसिस पे हमने क्या किया था
जीटीएफ ऑफ विन फे गए और जीटीएफ ऑफ विन पे
उसके अगेंस्ट हमने एक एक्सलेट फाइंड आउट
किया और उसको डायरेक्टली कट कॉपी पेस्ट
किया और हमें सक्सेसफुली रूट एक्सेस मिल
गया था अभी तक हमने जो भी कुछ परफॉर्म
किया ऑलरेडी जो एक स्टेप था नेस प्रज
केलेशन का वाया सुडो प्रिजेस वो आप
परफॉर्म कर चुके हो इसलिए उसके बारे में
मुझे आपको पढ़ाने की जरूरत भी नहीं है
क्योंकि दो से तीन ले में तो मैंने आपको
परफॉर्म करके ही दिखाया और आप अभी तक वो
परफॉर्म करते आए हुए हैं तो उसकी आपको
जरूरत नहीं है क्योंकि वो फालतू में आपको
बोर ही करेगा तो जो नेक्स्ट दो स्टेप बन
गए जो आज मैं आपको बताने वाला हूं कि एस
यू आईडी और वीक परमिशन हम चेक करने वाले
जो दो स्टेप्स होते हैं कि उसके बेस पर हम
कैसे न्यूमरेशन परफॉर्म करते हैं उसके बेस
पर कैसे इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर करेंगे देन हम
प्र एलेशन कैसे करेंगे वो मैं आपको
बताऊंगा ये कांसेप्ट क्या है ये फुल
कांसेप्ट आपको एक्सप्लेन करूंगा बिफोर दैट
हम सबसे पहले एक बार चेक करते हैं कि क्या
सुडो प्रिज के थ्रू हम एक्सेस ले सकते हैं
या नहीं ले सकते देखो हम क्या करेंगे सुडो
हाइ फन एल करते हैं सुडो हाइफ एल जैसे हम
परफॉर्म करेंगे हमें पासवर्ड मांग रहा
कंट्रोल शिफ्ट v हमने पासवर्ड एंटर किया
ये देखिए सॉरी यूजर रोबोट मे नॉट रन शड ऑन
द
[संगीत]
जब सुडो भी हान व भी यूज करोगे हान कैपिटल
व हम चेक करें तो यह इसका वर्जन है अभी ये
सुडो वर्जन आपको देखने को मिल गया सूडो
वर्जन
1.8.9 p5 ठीक है इसके अगेंस्ट आप क्या कर
सकते हो कोई एक्सप्लो फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश कर सकते हो बट यह भी आप कर चुके हो
अगर आपको याद हो मैंने आपको सिखाया नहीं
था बस एज ए टास्क आपको परफॉर्म करने के
लिए बोला था शायद बेसिक पन टेस्टिंग थी
उसमें आपको
जो एक्सप्लोइट करना था मशीन को या मशीन का
एक्सेस लेना था कंप्लीट वो यही ऑप्शन था
कि आपका जो सुडो का वर्जन था जो वल्नरेबल
था तो उसके अंदर जो वनबिल थी उसकी हेल्प
से आपने क्या किया था एक्सप्लोइट यूज किया
और आपने सक्सेसफुली रूट एक्सेस ले लिया था
बट अभी नहीं ले पाएंगे तो अभी हम दूसरी
टेक्निक प चलते हैं तो ये सुडो का वर्जन
है देन नेक्स्ट टेक्निक हमारी क्या रहेगी
अभी हम क्या करें
कि एयूआईडी के जो बाइंडीज है उसमें अ
फाइंड आउट करना वीक फाइल परमिशन को फाइंड
आउट करना कर्नल लेवल पे जाना देर आर लॉट
ऑफ ऑप्शंस आर अवेलेबल बट अभी हम सबसे पहले
फोकस करेंगे कि जो हमारा आज का जो टॉपिक
है वीक परमिश या हम बात करने वाले एयूआईडी
बाइनरीज को कैसे एक्सप्लोइट कर सकते हैं
और उनकी हेल्प से हम कैसे फर्द रूट एक्सेस
ले सकते हैं किसी भी मशीन के अंदर
ड्यूरिंग पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन तो वह करने से पहले हम सबसे
पहले कुछ बेसिक कांसेप्ट है जो मैं आपको
एक्सप्लेन करना चाहता हूं तो आर यू रेडी
टू गेन द नॉलेज ऑफ बेसिक कांसेप्ट
रिगार्डिंग टू द एसू आईडी
आर यू
रेडी तो चलो चलते हैं फिर हम तो नेक्स्ट
जो स्टेप आपका प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन में आपका है स्टेप नंबर फोर
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन तो आप देख पा रहे हो
स्टेप वन स्टेप थ्री हमने कर लिया है
स्टेप फोर पे है जो आपका प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन है अभी हम किसका प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन कर रहे हैं हम लिनक्स प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन कर रहे हैं फर्द अपने प्रिविलेज
को चेंज करने क्योंकि अभी हमारे पास मशीन
के अंदर को कोई भी प्रिविलेजेस नहीं है हम
एक नॉर्मल यूजर्स हैं जिसके पास कोई भी
प्रिविलेज नहीं है तो हम कैसे परफॉर्म कर
सकते हैं प्रिज एस्केलेशन तो सबसे पहले
मैं आपको सिखाता हूं कि एक इंपोर्टेंट
कांसेप्ट होता है
फाइल सिक्योरिटी रेफर टू कंट्रोलिंग
प्रोसेस कंट्रोलिंग एक्स आई एम सॉरी
कंट्रोलिंग एक्सेस प्रोटेक्टिंग
इंटीग्रिटी एंड
इंश्योरिटी ऑफ फाइल्स यूजिंग परमिश
इंक्रिप्शन एंड एक्सेस कंट्रोल मैकेनिज्म
बेसिकली फाइल सिक्योरिटी का मतलब मेरा है
कि फाइल के ऊपर एक्सेस को कंट्रोल करना
उसकी इंटीग्रिटी को मेंटेन करना और साथ के
साथ जो कॉन्फिडेंशियल्टी है फाइल्स की
उसको भी मेंटेन करना अब वो हम कैसे मेंटेन
कर सकते हैं परमिशन की हेल्प से फाइल को
एंक्रिप्ट करके और उसके ऊपर एक्सेस
कंट्रोल मैकेनिज्म लगाकर सिंस
[संगीत]
डाटा होगा वो ब्रिच होने से बच जाएगा साथ
के साथ जो सिस्टम कंप्रोमाइज होने के
चांसेस होंगे जिसकी हम बात करते हैं
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन की उससे भी आप बच
जाओगे अगर आपने अपने लिनक्स के अंदर फाइल
सिक्योरिटी को मेंटेन किया हुआ है जो फाइल
सिक्योरिटी किसका पार्ट आपका सिस्टम हार्ड
निंग का तो व्हाई इज द फाइल सिक्योरिटी
इंपोर्टेंट इन
करते हैं फाइल सिक्योरिटी का यूज करते हैं
दूसरा इंटीग्र सिस्टम की इंटीग्रिटी को
इंश्योर करने के लिए थर्ड प्रिवेंट डेटा
लॉस और करप्शन थर्ड की अगर कोई
कॉन्फिडेंशियल डाटा कोई कीज है या कोई
पासवर्ड्स है या कुछ ऐसी इंपोर्टेंट
कॉन्फिन फाइल्स हैं जो किसी के पास नहीं
होनी चाहिए तो उसको लॉस होने से या उसको
करप्ट होने से भी हम क्या करते हैं बचा
सकते हैं फाइल सिक्योरिटी मेंटेन करके
मिटिगेट प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन रिस्क सबसे
बड़ा रिस्क होता है किसी भी सिस्टम में कि
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन उस रिस्क को भी हम
क्या कर सकते हैं कम कर सकते हैं प्रिवेंट
मालवेयर्स एंड एक्सप्लोइट और उसके बाद अगर
फाइल सिक्योरिटी को अच्छे से मेंटेन किया
गया है तो उसके बाद हम फर्द एक्सप्लोइटेशन
को भी रोक सकते हैं या किसी भी मालवेयर को
एंटर करने से रोक सकते हैं अपनी मशीन के
अंदर दीज आर द मेन रीजन फॉर फाइल
सिक्योरिटी अभी हम बात करते हैं कि
क बिनेशन ऑफ स्टैंडर्ड फाइल परमिशन एडवांस
फाइल परमिश बाय चेंजिंग ओनरशिप इंक्रिप्शन
एंड एक्सेस कंट्रोल मैकेनिज्म इतनी सारी
चीजें यूज करके क्या करता है आपका नेक्स
फाइल सिक्योरिटी को मेंटेन करता है तो
सबसे पहले हम बात करते हैं कि स्टैंडर्ड
फाइल परमिश
कैसे मेंटेन की जाती है तो फॉर एग्जांपल
जैसे ही आप अपनी मशीन में एलएस हाइन एल
आईच करोगे तो वहां पर इस तरीके की आपको
इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को मिलेगी कुछ नंबर्स
कुछ डी आर डब् एक्स आर एक्स आर एक्स फिर
उसके बाद 2 5 समथिंग फिर रूट रूट फिर इसका
कुछ 4.0 के या समथिंग 1.2 एबी उसके बाद
फैब 25 सोनस डॉक्यूमेंट डॉक्यूमेंट लार्ज
फाटी ये सारी चीजें आपको देखने को मिलेंगी
तो चलो इस इंफॉर्मेशन के बारे में थोड़ा
डिटेल्स डिस्कस करते हैं कि यह इंफॉर्मेशन
क्या है और एज ए पेंटेस्ट इस इंफॉर्मेशन
के बारे में आपको पता होना चाहिए तो देखिए
सबसे पहले जो आपने ये फील्ड देखा होगा कुछ
नंबर 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 ये एक आय नोड नंबर
होता है ले के अंदर हर एक फाइल का एक
यूनिक
आइडेंटिफिकेशन नंबर होता है जिससे उस फाइल
को आइडेंटिफिकेशन
होती है एक तो फाइल टाइप होता है और उसके
बाद दूसरी इंफॉर्मेशन होती है कि इस फाइल
के ऊपर ओनर को क्या परमिशन है ग्रुप को और
अदर यूजर्स को क्या परमिशन ये सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन इसके अंदर होती है जो थर्ड
फील्ड आपने देखा होगा वहां पर 2 फव लिखा
होगा तो नंबर ऑफ हार्ड लिंग्स या सिबलिंग
लिंक्स जिनको हम बोलते हैं उसके कितने
डुप्लीकेट्स क्रिएट किए गए हैं उनका कितना
डुप्लीकेट नहीं बोल सकते आप उनको हार्ड
लिंक और सॉफ्ट लिंक होता है आपका सिंबॉलिक
लिंक्स होते हैं लिनक्स के अंदर तो उसकी
काउंटिंग रहती है थर्ड फोर्थ जो आपको रूट
देखने को मिल रहा वो ओनर्स होता है फाइल
का दो उसके बाद फिफ्थ फील्ड होगा उसके
अंदर ग्रुप ओनर्स ऑफ फाइल कौन है देन उसके
4.0 जो के आपको देखने को मिला होगा वो एक
साइज होता है ह्यूमन रीडेबल फॉर्म में
उसके फब 25 ये लास्ट मॉडिफाई डेट एंड टाइम
के साथ देन उसके बाद जो डॉक्यूमेंट आप देख
यहां पर फाइल नेम होता है अभी हमारा जो
हमें जो मतलब है हमें इस लाइन से मतलब है
बिकॉज वीी आर डूइंग प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
और प्रि एस्केलेशन में भी हम बात करने
वाले हैं फाइल सिक्योरिटी की तो फाइल
सिक्योरिटी में हमें सिर्फ इससे मतलब अभी
तो अभी इसके अंदर दो टाइप्स की इंफॉर्मेशन
है जो फर्स्ट जो इंफॉर्मेशन होती है वो
होती है आपकी फाइल टाइप अब फाइल टाइप
डायरेक्टर भी हो सकती है कोई सॉकेट फाइल
हो सकती है कोई या नॉर्मल फाइल्स हो सकती
है या कोई लिंक फाइल सिंबॉलिक लिंक फाइल
हो सकती है कुछ भी हो सकता है देन जो
सेकंड फील्ड आता है इसके अंदर भी आरडब्लू
एक जो तीन आपको कैरेक्टर देखने को मिलेंगे
यहां पर जो तीन कैरेक्टर के अंदर कौन सी
इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को मिलती है जो ओनर्स
होता है उसको इस फाइल के ऊपर क्या परमिश
है वो देखने को मिलेगी जो नेक्स्ट तीन जो
डिजिट टाइप का आपको देखने को मिले तीन
कैरेक्टर्स हैं आर फिर डैश और x तो इसके
अंदर जो इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को मिलती है
यहां पर आपके जो ग्रुप्स की जो परमिश है
वो देखने को मिलती है उसके बाद लास्ट में
जो थर्ड तीन वो पॉइंट बच गए तीन जो
कैरेक्टर्स बच गए r ड और x यहां पर जो
अदर्स यूजर्स होते हैं मशीन के अंदर उनको
क्या परमिशन है इस फाइल के ऊपर या इस
डायरेक्टर के ऊपर वह सारी यहां पर मेंटेन
की जाती है तो इस चीज को हम देखकर या इस
कॉलम को इस फील्ड को देखकर हम
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
डिफाइंड है इसके बेस पर ही हम क्या करते
हैं फर्द स्टेप अ आगे बढ़ते हैं तो यहां
तक सबको क्लियर है एवरीवन टिल नाउ
क्लियर एवरीवन क्लियर टिल
नाउ यहां तक सबको क्लियर
है पला आई एम सॉरी बात ऐसी है कि जब
कांसेप्ट के बीच में मैं आपके वो चैट आपके
ओनली मतलब के लिए नहीं हूं मैं आपकी जो
चैट है मैं अब कांसेप्ट के बीच में आपकी
चैट लूंगा तो दिस इज नॉट गुड अगर आपको
अपने पॉइंट रखना है तो क्लास के एंड में
रखिए बाद में उसका जवाब मिलेगा
आपको तो ओके तो अभी नेक्स्ट स्लाइड प चलते
हैं हम तो अभी जो फाइल टाइप्स होती है तो
उनके कुछ जो कैरेक्टर सिंबल्स होते हैं आप
एक बार गो थ्रू कीजिए व देख लीजिए जैसे कि
आपको डेस मिलेगा तो एक रेगुलर फाइल होती
है डी डायरेक्टरी होती है एल सिंबॉलिक
लिंक होता है बी ब्लॉक डिवाइस हो है ब्लॉक
डिवाइस मतलब आपके जो हार्ड ड्राइव है
या जो आपकी डीवीडी है उनकी इंफॉर्मेशन
मिलती है सी कैरेक्टर डिवाइस फाइल होती है
देन पी आपका नेम पाइप जो आईपीसी है उनकी
को फाइल होगी ए फॉर सॉकेट फाइल की
इंफॉर्मेशन मिलेगी अगर आपको यह सारे लिंक
देखने ये सारे कैरेक्टर देखने को मिलते
हैं फाइल टाइप में तो आप ऑटोमेटिक आपको
समझ जाना चाहिए कि फाइल का टाइप कौन सा है
तो उसके बाद अगर हम बात करते हैं कि या
परमिश की बात करता हूं कि डैश डैश आरडब्लू
एक्स ड आर ड ड आर का मतलब रीड होता है डबल
का मतलब राइट होता है एक्स का मतलब
एग्जीक्यूट होता है अब इसका मतलब क्या डैश
का मत मतलब क्या होता है कोई भी परमिश
नहीं फॉर एग्जांपल आगे इसको हम कैसे रीड
आउट कर जो यूजर्स है उसको रीड और राइट की
परमिशन है जो ओनर्स है जो ग्रुप है उसको
ओनली रीड परमिशन है जो अदर यूजर्स है उसको
भी ओनली रीड परमिशन है इस तरीके से इस
फाइल को पढ़ा जाता है तो नेक्स्ट अब बात
करते हैं हम कि जो फाइल सिक्योरिटी है वो
एडवांस फाइल परमिशन के द्वारा कैसे मेंटेन
की जाती है तो इन एडिशन टू द थ्री मेन
फाइल परमिश जो तीन मेन फाइल परमिशन थी रीड
राइट और एग्जीक्यूट इनके अलावा
[संगीत]
में जो परमिशन होती है तो सबसे एंड में
उसी में मिलेगा आपको प्लस टी सिंबल यह एक
स्पेशल परमिशन होती है
[संगीत]
इसका मतलब सीधा सा मतलब इसका जो ओनर्स है
या जो रूट यूजर्स है वही इसी फाइल को
मॉडिफाई या डिलीट कर सकता है उसके अलावा
कोई थर्ड पार्टी यूजर्स या कोई भी थर्ड
यूजर्स भले ही उसको राइट परमिश हो उसके
अंदर कोई भी मॉडिफिकेशन या उस फाइल को
डिलीट नहीं कर सकता अब इसकी की फीचर्स
क्या होते हैं कि प्रिवेंट अनऑथराइज्ड
फाइल डिलीट इनसाइड शेयर डायरेक्टरीज हो
सकता है कि कोई एक कंपनी है एक डेवलपमेंट
ग्रुप है एक डेवलपमेंट टीम है जो किसी
शेयर्ड प्रोजेक्ट पे काम कर रहे हैं वहां
पर पता चला कि किसी को अपने
खुंदक निकालने के लिए किसको बदला लेने के
लिए उसकी फालतू की नेसेसरी फाइल को
मॉडिफाई कर दिया जब बस ने देखा तो उस परे
प्रॉब्लम आ गई ओनली द फाइल ओनर डायरेक्टरी
ओनर और रूट कैन डिलीट द फाइल्स अप्लाई टू
डायरेक्टरीज ओनली एज इट यूज ऑन फाइल इ
डिप्री केटेड कॉमनली फाउंड इन मल्टी यूजर
सिस्टम एंड शेयर्ड फोल्डर्स ओके तो अगर
आपको स्टिकी बिट फाइल्स को फाइंड आउट करना
है तो आप फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं बाकी इसका
इतना रोल नहीं रहता हमारा उसमें क्या बोल
सकते हैं हम लिनक्स में आपको जस्ट फॉर
इंफॉर्मेशन
फाइंड ड का इसका क्या मतलब हैय जो पाइप
सिंबल आपको फॉरवर्ड स्लस देखने को मिल रहा
है इसका क्या मतलब है कोई बता सकता है एनी
वन
नहीं
पता कैसे हैकर बनोगे यार फंडामेंटल क्लियर
नहीं है
इसका मतलब होता है कि आपका जो रूट समझ रहे
हो पूरे फाइल सिस्टम का रूट क्योंकि जो
आपका जो फाइल सिस्टम स्टार्ट होता है
लिनक्स के अंदर वह आपके रूट से स्टार्ट
होता है तो यह वोह रूट है इसके सबसे इसके
बाद य सारी फाइल क्या करती है अवेलेबल
रहती हैं ओके तो उसके बाद डायरेक्टरी
परमिशन ये 1000 मतलब स्टिकी बिट चेक किया
जा रहा है और स्लश नल फाइल कैसा होल होता
है लिनक्स के अंदर यहां पर आप कितने भी
फाइल इसके अंदर एरर फाइल को डालोगे यह कभी
भरता ही नहीं बेसिकली यू कैन से दैट ब्लैक
होल नाउ उसके बाद हम बात करते हैं कि
व्हाट इज एसजी आईडी सेट ग्रुप आईडी क्या
होता है ये चीजें आपको पता होनी चाहिए एज
ए
ऑफ द फाइल इंस्टेड ऑफ यूजर एस्टिंग
एग्जीक्यूटिंग इट बेसिकली क्या होता है कि
जो एसजीआईडी का है जो बिट है या एसजीआईडी
जो ग्रुप आईडी होती है सेट ग्रुप आईडी
उसका यूज हम ग्रुप ओनरशिप को मेंटेन करने
के लिए यूज करते हैं एसजीआईडी इज ए
पावरफुल लिनेक्स परमिशन मैकेनिज्म यूज्ड
इन मल्टी यूजर एनवायरमेंट टू कंट्रोल
ग्रुप बेस्ड फाइल एक्सेस इट इज वाइडल
यूज्ड इन इंटरप्राइज एप्लीकेशंस
इंक्लूडिंग डेवलपमेंट टीम्स आईटी
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स डेटा बेसस एंड वेब
सर्वर्स कॉमनली यूज किया जाता है हाउ एवर
मिसयूज ऑफ एसजीआईडी कैन लीड टू प्रिज
बेसिकली वी कैन सेट हम कह सकते हैं कि कोई
किसी भी फाइल को जब भी कोई यूजर
एग्जीक्यूट करता है तो नॉर्मली क्या होता
है फाइल उस यूजर के अकाउंट से ही
एग्जीक्यूट होती है उसी यूजर के जो ओनरशिप
होती है उसी से एग्जीक्यूट होती है लेकिन
अगर उसके ऊपर एसजी आईडी मिट लगी हुई है तो
वो यूजर्स भले ही उसके पास कोई भी परमिश
हो एसजीआईडी बिट के केस में अगर वो उस
ग्रुप का पार्ट नहीं है तो उस फाइल को
एग्जीक्यूट नहीं कर सकता ओके फॉर एग्जांपल
इन ए सॉफ्टवेयर कंपनी मल्टीपल डेवलपर्स
वर्क ऑन द सेम प्रोजेक्ट इंस्टेड ऑफ
मैनुअली चेंज फाइल परमिशन एसजीआईडी
इंश्योर ऑल न्यू फाइल्स बिलोंग टू द
करेक्ट ग्रुप फॉर एग्जांपल ये एक
डायरेक्टरी है प्रोजेक्ट नाम की एक
डेवलपर्स नाम का ग्रुप है और जो
प्रोजेक्ट्स है इसका जो ग्रुप है जो ग्रुप
ओनर है वो डेवलपर्स है और इसके ऊपर परमिश
ये हैं आपकी एसजी आईडी बिट परमिशन लगा द
तो कोई भी यूजर्स होगा डेवलपर ग्रुप का इस
फाइल के इसके अंदर कोई भी फाइल क्रिएट कर
सकता है इस प्रोजेक्ट डायरेक्टर के अंदर
एंड दे विल ऑटोमेटिक बिलॉन्ग टू द डेवलपर
और जैसे ही वो फाइल उसके अंदर क्रिएट होगी
तो उसका जो ग्रुप ओनरशिप होगी व डेवलपर ही
होगी ना कि जिस यूजर ने उस फाइल को क्रिएट
किया जिस यूजर ने उस फाइल नई फाइल क्रिएट
की काम किया और उसके अंदर प्रोजेक्ट वाली
जो डायरेक्टरी के अंदर सेव कर दिया तो
नॉर्मली क्या होता है कि वह आपके ग्रुप
ओनरशिप के साथ सेव हो जाती है लेकिन इस
केस में ऐसा नहीं होगा अभी मैं सेकंड
एग्जांपल आपको बताता हूं देखो अभी
एसजीआईडी ने फाइल फाइल के केस में क्या
होता है व्हेन सेट ऑन ए बाइनरी
एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल द एग्जीक्यूटिंग यूजर
इन्हेरिटेंस
वह एग्जीक्यूट करेगी ग्रुप के प्रज जैसे
कि ये डेवलपर थी तो डेवलपर ग्रुप के
प्रिविलेजेस के साथ वो एग्जीक्यूट करेगी
व्हेन यूज्ड व्हेन स्पेसिफिक कमांड नीडेड
कंट्रोल ग्रुप लेवल एक्सेस अब एसजीआईडी
बिट अगर डायरेक्टरी के ऊपर लगी हुई है तो
इंश्योर दैट न्यू फाइल्स
क्रिएटेडटेड द ग्रुप्स ओनरशिप इंस्टेड ऑफ
द क्रिएट अ प्राइमरी ग्रुप समझ में आया कि
अगर किसी भी डायरेक्टरी के अंदर एसजीआईडी
बिट लगी हुई है ये आपको देखने को मिलेगा
जो ग्रुप वाला पार्ट है वहां पर आपको एस
देखने को मिलेगा सिंबल पूरे जहां पे रीड
राइट और एग्जीक्यूट होता है यहां पर रीड
राइट एस देखने को मिलेगा तो उस डायरेक्टरी
के अंदर आप जैसे ही कोई फाइल क्रिएट करोगे
तो उसका जो ग्रुप ओनरशिप होगी वो
डायरेक्टली कौन सी होगी आपकी जैसे डेवलपर
तो डेवलपर ही होगी तो हेल्प इन टीम कोलबेन
वेयर ऑल फाइल शुड बिलोंग टू स्पेसिफिक
सबको एसजीआईडी समझ में आया
अमन गुप्ता जी आप मे से जो सवाल पूछ रहे
हो कि व्ट काइंड ऑफ हैकिंग यू आर टीचिंग
तो
बच्चे आप आप जिस टाइप की पढ़ के आए हो जिस
टाइप के पढ़ने के लिए सोच रहे हो उसके लिए
आप सच में बहुत बच्चे हो ठीक
है मुझे पता है किस तरीके से किस चीज को
पढ़ाना है और किस तरीके कहां फंडामेंटल
क्लियर करने हैं
ओके तो आप अभी स्क्रिप्ट केडी ही हो तो
वैसे ही रहोगे
कमेंट करना आसान होता है अमन गुप्ता जी और
चीजें सीखना मुश्किल होता है तो मैं यही
बोलूंगा अगर कमेंट करने की बजाय थोड़ा सा
ध्यान देकर पढ़ोगे तो आपके लिए बेनिफिशियल
होगा
ओके तो जब आपको टॉपिक का नहीं पता तो
पढ़िए एक बार क्या है मैं जो पढ़ा रहा हूं
ध्यान से पढ़िए उसके बाद मेरे को
बोलिए ओके तो एसजी आडी बिट्स आई थिंक सबको
क्लियर हो गया होगा
तो
नेक्स्ट अभी एयू आईडी की बात करते हैं जो
हमारा मेन टॉपिक है आज और जिसके थ्रू हम
अपनी मशीन को एक्सप्लोइट करने वाले हैं
जिसके थ्रू जो पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेड करने
वाले जिसके ू अभी हमारे पास क्या है कि एक
लो लेवल का एक्सेस है एक टारगेट मशीन के
ऊपर मुझे फर्द उस मशीन को पूरा कंट्रोल
करना मुझे रूट एक्सेस चाहिए तो आज आज मैं
एसू आईडी की हेल्प से उसका पूरा कंट्रोल
लेने वाला हूं वो भी मैनुअल टेक्निक तो व
हम कैसे करेंगे तो सबसे पहले हम जानते हैं
कि एयू आईडी होता क्या है देन उसके बाद हम
कैसे फाइंड आउट करेंगे एसू आईडी सेट यूजर
आईडी इज अ स्पेशल परमिशन इन नेक्स एंड
व्हेन अप्लाइड दिस परमिशन प्रोवाइड्स
यूजर
सॉरी यूजर्स विद द एबिलिटी टू एग्जीक्यूट
ए स्क्रिप्ट और बाइनरी विद द परमिशन ऑफ
फाइल ओनर एज अपोज टू द यूजर दैट इज रनिंग
द स्क्रिप्ट और बाइनरी कहने का मतलब जो
एयूआईडी जो बिट है इसको हम बिट बोल सकते
हैं जो एडवांस सिक्य फाइल सिक्योरिटी होती
है बेसिकली यूजर्स के लिए होती है यूजर्स
के यूजर्स वाला जो फील्ड होता है आपका जो
डेटा टाइप उसके बाद यूजर्स की परमिशन होती
है फिर ग्रुप की परमिशन होती है देन अदर्स
यूजर की परमिशन हो तो ये जो जहां पर लगती
है ये यूजर्स वाले कॉलम में लगती है तो
वहां पर देखने को मिलता है यह पर यह
स्पेशली यूजर्स के लिए है अगर जिस फाइल के
ऊपर अगर आपकी एसू आईडी परमिश लगी हुई है
उस केस में क्या होता है
कि उस फाइल को जब आप एग्जीक्यूट करोगे या
उस बाइनरी फाइल को या स्क्रिप्ट को जैसे
ही रन करोगे तो
वह जो ओनर है उसका उस फाइल का उसी ओनर के
प्रिविलेज से वह फाइल क्या करेगी रन करेगी
रदर देन जब भी आप किसी फाइल को रन करते हो
नॉर्मल फाइल को विदाउट दिस एयूआईडी बिट तो
वो आपके प्रिविलेज से क्या करती है फाइल
रन करती है और उसको रिस्ट्रिक्शन होता है
लेकिन यहां पर उल्टा है यहां पर क्या होता
है अगर एयूआईडी बिट लगी हुई है आपकी फाइल
के ऊपर तो वह फाइल आपके जो ओनर है जिस
फाइल जिस ओनर ने उस फाइल को या उस बाइनरी
फाइल को क्रिएट किया होगा उसी के पिलीज से
क्या करेगी वो रन करेगी तो एयूआईडी परमिश
आर टिपिकली यूज्ड टू प्रोवाइड
अनप्रिविलेज्ड यूजर्स विद द एबिलिटी टू रन
स्पेसिफिक स्क्रिप्ट और बाइनरी विद रूट
परमिशन बेसिकली ज्यादातर यह क्या होता है
कि अनपीलेड यूजर्स होते हैं जिनके पास
प्रिजेस नहीं होते अगर किसी स्पेसिफिक
स्क्रिप्ट को या बाइनरी फाइल को रन करने
के लिए रूट परमिशन चाहिए तो उस केस में
एसू आईडी परमिश का यूज किया जाता है और
स्ल ईटीसी स्ल पास्ट शैडो जो फाइल होती है
वो एक एग्जांपल्स है या आपकी जो स् सीटीसी
पास
डब्ल्यूडीसीडब्ल्यू
ए प्रोग्राम इट रन विद द यूजर्स ऑन प्र
नॉर्मली मैं बताया कि जब भी आप किसी
प्रोग्राम को एग्जीक्यूट करते हो एज ए
नॉर्मल य तो वो आप ही के प्रिस्ट से क्या
करती है फाइल या प्रोग्राम रन करता है बट
इन केस ऑफ एयूआईडी बिट प्रोग्राम्स रन विद
द फाइल ओनर्स प्रिविलेजेस व्हिच कुड बी
रूट दिस इज पर्टिकुलर यूजफुल टू
एग्जीक्यूटेबल दैट रिक्वायर्स हायर
प्रिविलेजेस फॉर सर्टेन लेवल्स ऑपरेशंस बट
शुड स्टिल बी एक्सेसिबल टू ए नॉर्मल यूजर
व ट अंडरस्टूड है हाउ एवर इफ इंप्रोपर्ली
कॉन्फिडो यूजर्स अगर उनको सही से कंफिल
नहीं किया दिया गया कैन एक्सप्लोइट मिस
कॉन्फिडेंस और वल्नरेबल कीज विद इन द
बाइनरी और स्क्रिप्ट टू ऑब्टेन एन एलिवेटर
सेस अगर इस तरह की फाइलों को सही से कंफिल
नहीं किया गया तो क्या होगा कि उसकी मिस
कॉन्फिन के कारण या उसके अंदर वल्नरेबल
कीज होने के कारण वो फाइल्स वो बाइनरी
फाइल या स्क्रिप्ट क्या करेगी आप किसी भी
नॉर्मल यूजर को एलिवेटेड सेशन प्रोवाइड कर
देगी मतलब एडमिन एक्सेस प्रोवाइड कर देगी
या रूट एक्सेस प्रोवाइड कर देगी जिससे
क्या है कि कोई भी एक अटैकर्स उस मशीन को
फुल्ली कंप्रोमाइज कर
लेगा
नेक्स्ट एक्सप्लोइटिंग एसू आईडी बाइज द
सक्सेस ऑफ अटैक आवर अटैक विल डिपेंड ऑन द
फ्लोइंग फैक्टर अभी हमारा अटैक सक्सेस
होगा या नहीं होगा यह डिपेंड करता है इन
दो फैक्टर्स पे एक तो ओनर ऑफ द एयूआईडी
बाइनरी वी विल ओनली बी एक्सप्लोइटिंग
एयूआईडी बाइनरीज दैट आर ओन बाय द रूट
यूजर्स ऑफ द रूट यूजर्स और अदर प्लीज
यूजर्स बेसिकली अगर किसी भी एसू आईडी
बाइनरी कोई भी बाइनरी फाइल्स है या कोई
ऐसी फाइल्स अगर उसके ऊपर रूट प्रिविलेजेस
है या ऐसे सुपर यूजर प्रिविलेजेस हैं अगर
उस फाइल को हम एक्सप्लोइट करेंगे तभी हम
सक्सेस हो सकते हैं हर हर किसी एसडी वाली
बाइनरी फाइल को हम एक्सप्लोइट नहीं कर
सकते दूसरा उसके पास परमिशन होनी चाहिए वी
विल रिक्वायर एग्जीक्यूटेबल परमिशन इन
ऑर्डर टू एग्जीक्यूट द एयूआईडी बाइनरी
दूसरी सबसे इंपोर्टेंट बात यह है कि ओके
वी आर ए नॉर्मल यूजर्स फॉर एग्जांपल अभी
हमारे केस में रोबोट यूजर्स हैं तो अगर
मुझे एयूआईडी बाइनरी फाइल को क्या करना है
अगर एग्जीक्यूट करना है तो उसके लिए हमारे
पास एग्जीक्यूटेबल परमिशन होनी चाहिए उस
फाइल के ऊपर तभी मैं क्या कर सकता हूं उस
फाइल को क्या कर सकता हूं एक्सप्लोइट करके
अपना सेल एक्सेस ले सकते हैं तो अभी कुछ
चीट छट है कुछ बहुत सारी कमांड्स है जो
मैंने यहां पर आपके सामने लिखी हुई है
जिनका यूज करके हम फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं
कि सिस्टम के अंदर कितनी एसू आईडी बाइनरी
फाइल्स है कितनी एसजीआईडी बाइनरी फाइल्स
है वर्ल्ड लाइटे एबल फाइल्स और डायरेक्टरी
जिनकी वीक परमिशन जिनके ऊपर अवेलेबल है
ग्रुप की रा राइ टेबल फाइल्स कौन-कौन सी
है आपके सिस्टम के अंदर तो यह सारी एक बार
गो थ्रू करके देखते हैं देन उसके बाद हम
एक्सप्लोर करेंगे मशीन को तो देन गो टू
आवर मशीन और अभी हम एक्सेस करते हैं सबको
समझ में आ गया सय आईडी क्या होता है
एवरीवन
यह सर्टिफाइड हैकर मुझसे पूछ रहे होगे शाय
डाउट मेरे डाउट ले रहे हो क्या
आप ओके तो अभी हम चलते हैं एक बार यह रहा
तो सबसे पहले हम चेक करते हैं कि यह रहा
यह परमिशन चेक करते हैं कि एस यू आईडी
परमिशन इस फाइंड कमांड की हेल्प से फाइंड
आउट करते कंट्रोल सी देन गो टू आवर मशीन
और इसको हम क्या करते हैं अभी यह रहा यहां
पर कल v पेस्ट किया और अभी मैं जैसे इसको
रन करूंगा तो आपको पता चल जाएगा हिट एंटर
यह
देखिए यह वह सारी फाइल्स है जिनके ऊपर कौन
सी है एयूआईडी परमिश लगी हुई है कौन सी
स्ल बिन पिंग स्ल बिन अनमाउंट स्ल बिन
माउंट स्ल बिन पिंग सिक्स स्ल बिन एयू स्ल
अ स् यूजर बिन पास्ट ड्डी स् यूजर बिन
न्यू ग्रुप स् यूजर बिन सीएसएच दीज आर द
स्लैश यूजर बिन सुडो स्लैश इनके ऊपर सबके
ऊपर क्या है आपकी एस यूआईडी परमिश लगी हुई
है अगर आप ओनली रूट यूजर्स की देखना चाहते
हो कि ओनली रूट यूजर्स के ऊपर कौन-कौन सी
एस रूट यूजर्स के पास जो एस आडी वाली है
यह देखना चाहते हो तो यह भी देख सकते हो
देन अगेन अभी मैं आपको रन करके दिखा रहा
हूं देन उसके बाद हम एक्सप्लोइट करेंगे
कॉपी पेस्ट एंड हिट एंटर यह देखिए यह आपको
शो कर देगा नाउ अभी आप बिन पि ए मैप यह
देखिए सारी की सारी सब पर एग्जीक्यूट
परमिशन भी है देखिए ओके अदर्स यूजर्स को
एग्जीक्यूट परमिशन है ध्यान से ये कॉलम
देखिए रीड और एग्जीक्यूट रीड और
एग्जीक्यूट रीड और एग्जीक्यूट अदर यूजर्स
के लिए परमिशन होनी चाहिए नेक्स्ट अगर मैं
चेक करना चाहता हूं कि सिस्टम्स के अंदर
कितनी एसजीआईडी बाइनरीज है वो भी मैं चेक
कर सकता हूं देखिए क्योंकि एसजी आईडी
बाइनरीज की हेल्प से भी आप क्या कर सकते
हो फाइल को सिस्टम में नक्स प एलेशन परम
कर सकते कट कॉपी एंड पेस्ट यह देखिए यह
सारी की सारी आपकी क्या है एसजी आईडी
ग्रुप आईडी वाली फाइल से देखिए स्क्रीन
मेल अनलॉक मेल लॉक क्रोन टैब चेज
एक्सपायरी देन वल दज ऑल आर द योर एसजी
आईडी अगर आप ओनली ग्रुप नेम के साथ भी कर
सकते हो जो फाइंड ग्रुप य पर ग्रुप का नाम
उसकी परमिशन देन इस तरीके से आप चेक कर
सकते हो अगर आपको यह चेक करनी है कि
सारी की सारी जितनी फाइल्स हैं और
डायरेक्टरी उनके ऊपर किस-किस को रीड और
राइट राइटबस है वर्ल्ड राइटेल परमिशन यह
भी चेक कर सकते हो ओनली फाइल के केस में
आप चेक कर सकते हो देखिए यह रहा तो हिट
एंटर यह काफी यूज़फुल इंफॉर्मेशन है आपको
कोई भी एक्सप्लोइट एंटर करने के लिए फर्द
और रिवर्स सेल एंटर करने के लिए टेंटर
देखिए तो दीज ऑल आर द वर्ल्ड राइ टेबल
परमिशन देखिए डायमंड डेमंड डायमन रूट रूट
रूट दीज ऑल आर द लिस्ट ऑफ द फाइल्स आप देख
सकते हैं
इसको यहां
देखिए तो दे लॉट ऑफ फाइल्स अभी डायरेक्टरी
अगर मुझे चेक करनी है तो मैं डायरेक्टरी
भी चेक कर सकता हूं कैसे देखिए इस कमांड
की हेल्प से अभी मैं डायरेक्टरी भी चेक कर
सकता हूं कंट्रोल सी देन उसके बाद
डायरेक्टरी की लिस्ट आउट भी कर सकते हैं
हम यहां पर देख सकते हो पेस्ट एंड हिट
एंटर यह देखिए दज ऑल आर द डायरेक्टरी जो
वर्ड रीटेबल और राइ टेबल है देखिए यह रहा
वर्ल्ड राइबल डायरेक्टरीज ये रही रन लक
वाटी एमपी प वार टी एम प अभी एक चीज ये
देखो कहीं पर टी दिख रहा है आपको टी का
मतलब क्या
है टी का मतलब क्या है फाइल में देखिए
ध्यान से टी का मतलब क्या
है का मतलब बताइए
एवरीवन नहीं नहीं नहीं नहीं अभी बताया था
मैंने
स्टिकी बिट यस उसके बाद अगर आप ओनली ये
देखना चाहते हो कि ग्रुप के ऊपर राइटबस
किस-किस को ओनली तो ये भी चेक कर सकते हो
तो फाइल के फाइल के ऊपर ये देखा कंट्रोल
सी एंड ये भी चेक कर सकते हो यहां पर अभी
देखिए क्लिपबोर्ड हिट ये रहा
तो ये कौन देखिए ये ही ग्रुप्स केनली राइ
टेबल परमिशन दज आर द फाइल्स ओके देन उसके
बाद ये भी चेक कर सकते हो एचजी आईडी और
एयूआईडी बैनरी दोज आर आल्सो वर्ल्ड राइट
बल जो काफी डेंजरस है यह भी चेक कर सकते
हो देखिए यह
रहा दज आर द कमांड्स वेरी वेरी इंपोर्टेंट
कमांड देखिए अभी ओनली स्लश नल मतलब इस
मामले में तो ये सही है नेक्स्ट स्लाइड पर
चलते हैं अगर आपको
वो फाइल्स फाइंड आउट करनी है या
डायरेक्टरीज फाइंड आउट करनी है जिनके ऊपर
ना कोई यूजर्स है ना कोई ओनर ग्रुप है
मतलब नो ओनर नो ग्रुप तो यह भी आप फाइंड
आउट कर सकते हो फाइंड कमांड की हेल्प से
तो सिंपली गो एंड पेस्ट यह रहा हिट एंटर
ऐसी कोई भी फाइल या डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
देन देन यह
रहा पेस्ट और यह
रहा यह इतनी सारी फाइल्स या फाइल्स है
जिनके ऊपर एग्जीक्यूटेबल परमिशन है ओके
जिनके ऊपर एग्जीक्यूटेबल परमिशन है सभी की
अगर आपको रीडेबल फाइंड फा जो सेंसिटिव
डाटा आपका एक्सपोज हो सकता है तो यह भी आप
चेक कर सकते हो यह
रहा कंट्रोल सी एंड अगेन यह रहा यह भी आप
चेक कर सकते हो ये देखिए मतलब बहुत सारी
फाइल्स और डायरेक्टरीज आर अवेलेबल अगर आप
कैट स्ल सटी शैडो फाइल भी चेक करना चाहिए
आपको हो सकता है इसका एक्सेस मिल जाए तो
आपके लिए तो बहुत अच्छा हो जाएगा
ओके हिट एंटर यह रहा यह रहा परमिशन डिनाइड
क्योंकि मुझे परमिशन नहीं है अभी ओनली
आपको फाइंडिंग फाइल रूट फाइल्स बाइनरी यू
कैन जिसको आप मॉडिफाई कर सको यह भी चेक कर
सकते हो तो मैक्सिमम सारी की सारी कमांड
मैंने आपको रन करके दिखा दिए हैं लेकिन कम
बैक टू आवर टॉपिक तो दीज ऑल आर द फाइल्स
ओके रूट ऑन बाइनरीज जिनको आप मॉडिफाई भी
कर सकते हो देन उसके बाद हम चलते हैं जो
सबसे पहले इंपोर्टेंट जो हमारा कांसेप्ट
था कि आप एसू आईडी के थ्रू कैसे हैक कर
सकते हो कैसे भी मशीन को वो कर सकते हो तो
गो बैक एंड अभी आपका क्या काम है इसको मैं
फुल टर्मिनल पे ओपन कर देते हैं एंड हिट
एंटर ये रहा पेस्ट और ये रहा तो दीज ऑल आर
द फाइल अभी यहां पर अगला सवाल मेरा आप
लोगों से है आपने तो मुझसे पूछा नहीं कि
सर हमें पता चल गया कि इतनी जो फाइल्स है
इन सबके ऊपर एस यू आईडी लगी हुई है यह
सबको पता चल गया ब सर एक्सप्लोइट कैसे
करेंगे हम एक्सप्लोइट कैसे
करेंगे बताइए हम इसको एक्सप्लोइट कैसे
करेंगे हमें पता चल गया कि दीज ऑल आर द
फाइल्स दैट आर एस यूआईडी परमिशन देन हम
इसको एक्सप्लोइट कैसे
करेंगे बताइए
यस बिल्कुल शुभम जीटीएफ विन के थ्रू हम
करेंगे ओके यहां पर देखिए पिंग अनमाउंट
माउंट पिंग सिक्स ये रहा अभी एक काम करना
पड़ेगा हमें हर एक फाइल को वन बाय वन बाय
चेक करना पड़ेगा कौन सी काम करेगी या नहीं
काम करेगी जिसके अगेंस्ट पब्लिकली अवेलेबल
एक्सप्लोइट है या नहीं है जीटीएफ बन पे हम
सबसे पहले जीटीएफ बन पे चलते हैं उसके बाद
देखते हैं कि कौन सा काम करेगा नहीं करेगा
तो जीटीएफओ बनस
क्या हुआ भाई डार्क वेब यूजर आपके पास तो
जवाब था
नहीं आईम डार्क वेब यूजर जस्ट सेइंग ट एंड
पूछा गया तो सवाल का जवाब नहीं आपके
पास ग्रेट ग्रेट
हैकर्स कम फ्रॉम ग्रेट
प्लेस ओके तो हम चेक करते हैं यह
रहा सबसे पहले इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है कि हम
सुडो लगता कि सुडो से रिलेटेड हमें कुछ
मिल जाएगा तो कॉप
सिलेक्शन एंड गो टू दिस वन हम पेस्ट करते
हैं एक बार चेक करते हैं कि सुडो से
रिलेटेड कुछ है सुडो के लिए है तो लेकिन
बाइनरी अगर हम चेक करें तो यहां पर क्या
है सुडो बिन एसए है तो इफ बाइनरी इ अलाउड
टू रन ए सुपर यूजर बाय
सुडो देखो इफ द बाइनरी इ अलाउड टू रन एज
सुपर यूजर बाय सुडो इट डज नॉट ड्रॉप द
एलिवेटेड प्लेजेस एंड मे बी यूज टू एक्सेस
द फाइल सिस्टम एंड स्लेट मेंटेन पलीज
एलेशन मे बी हम ट्राई करके देख सकते हैं
इट विल वर्क और नॉट बट हमें सुडो एक्सेस
है ही नहीं सुडो एक्सेस हमारे पास है ही
नहीं तो यह प्लीज हमारे लिए काम करेगा
नहीं बट व इंटरेस्टिंग दैट की यूजर लोकल
बिन और ए मैप तो क्यों ना हम ए मैप का
ढूंढ लेते हैं
एक ये
रहा गो
बैक पेस्ट एन मैप अभी एन मैप के लिए है
देखो क्लिक करेंगे सेल नॉन इंटरेक्ट
रिवर्स सेल नॉन टक्ट बाय एंड सेल फाइल
अपलोड फाइल अपलोड अभी सुडो लिमिटेड तो अभी
हम चेक करते हैं सेल से रिलेटेड ये देखिए
अभी यहां पर हम चेक करेंगे सेल से रिलेटेड
या फर्द और भी हम चेक
करेंगे आपको लगता है कि कौन सा काम करेगा
इसमें बताइए हमें कौन सा ट्राई करना
चाहिए यह नहीं है यह नहीं है फाइल अपलोड
हमें चाहिए नहीं फाइल डाउनलोड है नहीं
हमें फाइल रीड नो सुड वाला बेसिकली हमें
चाहिए
तो हमें क्या करना
पड़ेगा एस यू आईडी ओके इफ बाइनरी बिट सेट
इट डज नॉट ड्रॉप द एलिवेटेड प्लेज एंड मे
बी एक्यूज एक्सेस सोन सो देन दिस एग्जांपल
सुडो विच एन मैप सुडो इंस्टॉल फाइल टू
राइट देन उसके बाद विच वन
ये रहा सुडो इफ बाइनरी इज अलाउड टू रन एज
ए सुपर यूजर बाय सुडो इट डू नॉट ड्रॉप द
एलिवेटेड ब डज ओके सो इनपुट इको इ
डिसेबल्ड एंड इंटरेक्ट मोड अवेलेबल वर्जन
सन सो एग्जीक्यूट तो क्यों ना हम इसको
ट्राई करते हैं एक बार सुडो एन मैप
इंटरेक्ट अभी एयूआईडी बिट लगी हुई है हम
तो एक काम करते हैं एन मैप इंटरेक्ट ट्राई
करते हैं सुडो तो हमारा काम करेगा नहीं तो
इसको हम ट्राई करते
हैं कॉपी और आपको हिट एंड ट्राई करके
देखना है समझना है थोड़ा सा हिट एंड ट्राई
अब पेस्ट क्लिप बोर्ड हिट एंटर अभी यहां
पर देखिए एन मैप इंटरेक्ट ओपन देखो वर्जन
3 प 81 है तो और य यह वर्जन य किसके लिए
अवेलेबल है क्या 2.0 टू 5.21 तक इसको यूज
कर सकते हो उसके बाद यह यूज कर सकते हो
देन उसके बाद यह
रहा कॉपी एंड
पेस्ट पे द क्लिप पर्ड हिट एंटर अभी हमें
क्या मिल गया सेल मिल
गया ओके हमें सेल एक्सेस मिल गया देखिए
अभी हु एम
आई देखिए रूट यूजर्स आईडी चेक करू मैं तो
यह देखिए आई रूट यूजर 1002 रोबोट है ओके
रोबोट रोबोट रूट यूजर य आईडी ओके अगर मैं
क्या करता हूं सीडी और
होम एलस चेक करते हैं तो रोबोट ही है
लेकिन सीडी रूट पर चलते अभी
हम रूट होम डायरेक्टरी एलएस चेक करते हैं
देखो यहां पर थर्ड फाइल फर्स्ट बूट डन या
उसके बाद कीथ तो अभी हम कैट करके देखते
हैं और
कीथ कीथ देन उसके बाद की हान 3 हाइन ऑफ
हाइन डटी एक इस तरीके से हमने सक्सेसफुली
जो एसू आईडी बिट है उसके थ्रू हमने मशीन
को हैक कर लिया और कंप्लीट हमारे कंट्रोल
में अभी हमारी मशीन जो मशीन है पूरी अंडर
कंट्रोल हमारे ठीक हम कुछ भी कर सकते अभी
मशीन के अंदर क्योंकि हमारे
पास रूट एक्सेस है अभी हमारे पास क्या है
इस मशीन का रूट एक्सेस है और इस तरीके से
हमने तीनों फ्लैग फाइंड आउट कर लिए लेकिन
हमने काफी टाइम लगा दिया इसको सॉल्व करने
में क्योंकि मुझे कुछ कांसेप्ट थे जो आपको
सिखाने थे अभी मैं चाहूं तो कैट स्ल टीसी
शैडो फाइल को भी एक्सेस कर सकता
हूं कुछ भी कर सकता हूं देखो यह शैडो फाइल
देखिए वनिस माय एसक्यूएल ये इसका पासवर्ड
देखिए ये रहा ये रहा इसका पासवर्ड देन
उसके
बाद यह रहा यह रहा य यह रूट का
पासवर्ड
ओके सबको समझ में आया कि हमने कैसे लिनक्स
प्लीज एस्केलेशन किया विद दी हेल्प ऑफ एस
यूआईडी बाइंडीज वीक मिस कन्फर एयू आईडी
क्योंकि यहां पर एक एक्सप्लोइट अवेलेबल था
जीटीएफ बिन पर जो हमने सक्सेसफुल क्योंकि
अभी मुझे पता था एन मैप में है इसलिए
डायरेक्टली मैं उधर पहुंच गया लेकिन आपको
हिट एंड ट्राई करना
पड़ेगा आपको हिट एंड ट्राई करना पड़ेगा हर
एक को उसके बाद इस और भी स्टेप्स होते
हैं कॉर्पोरेट में अगर आप ट्राई करोगे कई
बार देखो आपको हकीकत बात बताता हूं कि आप
लोग विश्वास नहीं करोगे लेकिन
जब जो इंटरप्राइज एनवायरमेंट होता ना
उसमें भी आपको कितना लगता कि सिक्योर
होंगी एक एनवायरमेंट जिसके पास कोई भी
कंपनी है जिसके पास अगर ज्यादा पैसे नहीं
है अपने एनवायरमेंट को प्रोटेक्ट करने के
लिए चलो मैं आपके सवाल पर आ जाता हूं अभी
मशीन तो हमने सॉल्व कर ली मैं इसको बंद कर
देता हूं देन
क्लोज और शट डाउन उसके बाद मैं आप प आ
जाता हूं देखिए क्या हो गया कि अब एक
इंटरप्राइज एनवायरमेंट कंपनी का एग्जांपल
लीजिए किसी भी कंपनी के पास अगर कंपनी के
पास ज्यादा फंड नहीं है बिलियंस की कंपनी
नहीं है ज्यादा फंड वाली कंपनी नहीं है
आपको कितना लगता है कि वो कितना सिक्योर
होगी वोह क्या करते हैं कि अपनी थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस कर लेते हैं और रिस्क
मैनेजमेंट कर लेते हैं और उस परे भी
ज्यादा पैसा नहीं लगाते हैं अगर आप कोई
अच्छा शॉक एनालिस्ट होगा या शॉक
थ्रेट थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस वाला होगा या जो
सोकस टीम होगी या जो आपका बिजनेस एनालिसिस
परफॉर्म किया जाएगा तो आप वो सजेस्ट करते
बट कंपनी को बिजनेस से मतलब होता है
सिक्योरिटी बाद में यूज करती है अगर
ज्यादा बिलियंस कंपनी फ होगी बाकी जो
बड़ी-बड़ी कंपनियां होंगी वह खर्च करते
हैं पैसे फायरवॉल पे आईडीएस पे आईपीएस पे
या एडवांस जो फायर वाल्स है उन पर फोकस
करती हैं बट बात करते हैं यहां की जो जो
नॉर्मल कंपनीज होती हैं वह इतना पैसा खर्च
नहीं करती सिक्योरिटी पर लेकिन उनको पता
है कि मेरी मशीन में जो मेरा लोकल
एनवायरमेंट है कौन सी मशीन वल्नरेबल उनको
पता रहता है यह चीज ठीक है आपको कितने
लोगों को लगता है कि
[संगीत]
जो कोई भी एक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन इवन गवर्नमेंट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन भी की भी बात करें कितने
लोगों को लगता है कि फुली सिक्योर्ड
है देखिए पल
मैं आपको नहीं है एक चीज
बोलूंगा अगर आपको कांसेप्ट क्लियर ना हो
और आपको पन टेस्टिंग नहीं आती हो दूसरों
की हेल्प से कर लोगे गाइड भी कर देंगे बट
सोचिए आप क्या कर लोगे आप रिपोर्ट जमा
करवा दोगे सब कुछ कर लोगे बट प्रॉब्लम
वहां पर यह है कि अगर आप खुद से नहीं कर
पा रहे मैं आपको हिड करता हूं अच्छे से
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कीजिए अच्छे अच्छे
टूलों का यूज कीजिए नेसस का यूज कर लीजिए
उसके बाद निकटो यूज कर लीजिए देन न्यूक्लि
आई सबका यूज कीजिए और आइडेंटिफिकेशन कोई
एक्सप्लोइट है या नहीं है या एसक्यूएल जो
भी मिलता है ट्राई कीजिए और एक्स उसके बाद
एक्सप्लोइट कीजिए और देन फर्द ये
टेक्निक्स होती है पोस्ट एक्सप्लो में
जाइए इतना अगर आपके पास परमिशन है तो
लेकिन सबसे पहले आपके पास स्ट्रांग
इंफॉर्मेशन होनी चाहिए उसके बेस के बेस पर
आपके अपडेटेड टूल्स होने चाहिए वो आपको
यूज करने हैं वनटी स्कैनिंग जिसको बोलते
हैं वो अच्छे से परफॉर्म करोगे देन अगर
आपको लगता कि फिर भी आपको कोई भी कॉमन
मलटी नहीं मिल रही देन उसके बाद फिर आपके
जो वेब एप्लीकेशंस है वेब पन टेस्टिंग वा
जो होते है ज एसक्यूएल एक्सस सीसर आरफ या
अदर जो है एलएफ आई है आरसी ही है तो आप वो
ट्राई करके देखिए तो अब इतनी सारी चीज
आपको करनी आती है तो कीजिए
क्योंकि आप प्रेशर में आगे कोई चीज करने
की कोशिश करते हो कि मुझे अभी मिल गया
मौका मिल गया बट
मुझे नहीं पता कैसे करूं हां आपके पास
टेक्निक्स है टैक्टिक्स आपको आता है सब
कुछ पता है तो बस आपको हिट चाहिए होता कि
सर मुझे ये परफॉर्म करना है यह है अगर
आपको सब कुछ मतलब कि आपको आधा आता और आधा
नहीं आता तो उसके साथ आपके साथ बहुत सारी
प्रॉब्लम होती
है हां अब्दुल बोल रहे नथिंग इज सिक्योर
देखिए क्या होता है कि एंटरप्राइज
एनवायरमेंट में वह भी क्या करते हैं कि
अगर उनकी मशीन को पन टेस्ट करने के लिए
दिया जाएगा इवन कोई भी गवर्नमेंट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन की है ठीक है कि वो पब्लिक
सर्वर उतना ही एक्सपोज करते जितना जरूरत
है और बेसिक फायरवॉल का व यूज कर लेते हैं
देन उसके बाद क्या करते हैं लोकल इतने
सारे तो प्रिंटर यूज करते हैं शेयर पे तो
वहां पर किसका एसएमबी का यूज आ गया ठीक है
अब जहां पर एसएमबी आ गई तो आप आसानी से
अगर उसका एक्सेस मिल गया मतलब बेसिकली अगर
आपको सबसे पहला टास्क होता आपका किसी भी
एंटरप्राइज एनवायरमेंट में अगर आपको
इनिशियल एक्सेस चाहिए वह आपका इनिशियल
एक्सेस के लिए कोई भी टेक्निक हो सकती है
आपकी चाहे वो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग हो स है
फेसिंग हो सकती है फेक वाईफाई पॉइंट हो
सकता है आपको एक बार इनिशियल एक्सेस लेके
देखिए ट्रस्ट में उसके बाद जो मैं आपको
बता रहा हूं ना इतने मेंही आपको वनटी मिल
जाएगी क्योंकि अप टू डेट वे भी नहीं रखते
क्योंकि क्योंकि सबके पास एक प्रेशर है
अगर मैं अगर एक फॉर एग्जांपल मैं एक आईटी
इंजीनियर हूं आईटी टेक्निशियन हूं और मुझे
सारे सर्वर्स और सारी चीजों मैनेज करना है
तो मेरे पास वही काम नहीं होगा और भी सारी
चीजें होंगी तो मैं अंडर प्रेशराइज हूं
कभी मैं भूल जाऊंगा
कभी मैं कुछ ऐसी चीजें गलतिया कर दूंगा
हमेशा मैं भी अपडेट नहीं हूं तो डिपेंड
करता है ऑर्गेनाइजेशन टू ऑर्गेनाइजेशन पर
उनके फंड पर वह कितना खर्च करते
हैं हां अगर इंटरनेट से कनेक्ट हो तभी आप
वल्नरेबल होगे तो एक और तरीका है उसका भी
उसको बोलते हैं
हम क्लाइट सेड पन टेस्टिंग आप इंटरनेट से
कनेक्ट हो होगे तभी नहीं अगर आपकी पूरा
एंटर प्राइज एनवायरमेंट एक्सपोज नहीं है
फिर भी आपको अगर पन टेस्टिंग करनी है तो
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग इज द बेस्ट
वे आपको क्या करना है कनेक्ट हो जाओ सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग स्टार्ट करो वो खुद से आपको
करें ऐसा तो ऑप्शन नहीं हो सकता कि वो
कनेक्ट नहीं होंगे हो सकता कि पर्टिकुलर
एनवायरमेंट उससे नहीं लेकिन कोई ना कोई तो
सर्वर कुछ ना कुछ तो आपको डेफिनेटली काम
में आएगा या एक फेक एक्सेस पॉइंट बना के
या उसके आसपास एक मॉनिटरिंग कीजिए जाइए
पास में उसके बाद वहां पर फेक एक्सेस
पॉइंट वहां पर उनके कैंटीन या जहां पर बैठ
के देखिए वह कैसे एक दूसरे क्योंकि कहीं
ना कहीं तो इंटरनेट चलता ही है बिना
इंटरनेट पर कोई ऑर्गे नहीं
चलती देखिए ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में क्या होता है
कि आप जोब सीख रहे हो पन टेस्टिंग बिगनर
लेवल प आप कितने लोगों को यूज करने को
मिलता है मेटा स्ट प्रो वर्जन पेड वर्जन
नहीं मिलता फ्री में उतना ही है जो
लिमिटेड है लेकिन प्रो में ज्यादा
फैसिलिटी होती है जैसे आप क्रैक वर्जन यूज
करते हो किसका बब स्वीट का बट आप सोचिए कि
बब स्वीट का क्रैक वर्जन और एक विदाउट
क्रैक वर्जन जो लेटेस्ट है और वह आपको
अच्छे खासा डॉलर डॉलर में मिलता है वो
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में यूज करने को मिलता है और
उसके बाद आपको सडाउन है ओपन फ्री फुल पेड
वर्जन वाला फ्री मिलता यूज करने के लिए
मतलब जो इंडस्ट्री के टूल्स है जो महंगे
वाले टूल्स है जिनको आप एफर्ट भी नहीं कर
सकते उनके प्रो वर्जन आपको यूज करने के
मिल जाए तो उनके पास तो लेटेस्ट सीवी
अपडेट होती है जैसे एक्सप्लोइट जैसे कोई
भी वनटी आई उसको पैच हुआ उसका एक्सप्लोर
बना उनके डाटाबेस में अपडेट हो
गया तो एक बात बताइ वहां से ज्यादा अपडेट
है ना तो इसीलिए वहां पर एंटरप्राइज के
अंदर ज्यादा इजी हो जाता है क्योंकि आप जो
पन टेस्टिंग कर रहे होते हो आप ब्लैक बुक
पन टेस्टिंग और आपके पास जितनी रिसोर्सेस
अवेलेबल हो आप उन्ही रिसोर्सेस से आप वो
पन टेस्टिंग करते हो क्योंकि प्रो
रिसोर्सेस आप अफर्ड नहीं कर सकते इवन मैं
भी नहीं कर
सकता नोबडी कैन अफर्ड द प्रो लेवल्स बट एक
बार उसको यूज करना आता है और एक बार
एंटरप्राइज एनवायरमेंट एंटर करते हो आपके
जॉब लग जाती हो उसके बाद आप फ्री टू यूज
आप यूज कर सकते हो
उनको मेटा स्लट प्रो या मल्टी गो दज आर सो
हाई प्राइस टूल्स ओके समझने की कोशिश
कीजिए ब्लू जैकिंग बोलते हैं मे
बी तो किसी और कोई सवाल रिलेटेड टू द
कांसेप्ट
नहीं आदित्य सिंह आपको यही तो प्रॉब्लम है
देखो कि एक चीज होती है कि हमें कोई भी
कमांड है मुझे पता है तो पन टेस्टिंग के
केस में क्या होता है आप कोई एग्जाम भी
देते हो तो आपको याद नहीं करना कांसेप्ट
पता होना चाहिए बेसिक फंडामेंटल क्लियर
होने चाहिए और आपके पास वो चीज होनी चाहिए
और एक चीज को बारबार यूज करते हो इस जो
कमांड है फाइंड कमांड है इसको कहीं पर लिख
लोगे अपने नोट्स में ऑनलाइन नोट्स है इवन
वन नोट है या आपका गल डॉक्स है उसमें आप
यूज करोगे तो वहां पर आप लिख के रखिए और
उसका कोई नई आपको कमांड मिलती है वो भी
लिख के रखिए कौन सी कमांड काम करेगी नोबडी
नोज सिस्टम किस तरीके से कंफिल किया गया
नोबडी नोज इवन आप मेरे कोभी अभी बोलोगे कि
सर यह पेन टेस्ट करनी है आई कांट मुझे भी
नहीं पता कि मैं इसको अभी सेम टाइम में कर
पाऊंगा नहीं कर पाऊ बिकॉज उसकी हार्ड निंग
किस तरीके से की गई है उस सिस्टम को कैसे
कन्फर किया गया है उसको समझने में टाइम
लगता है एक मूवी नहीं है कि मूवी की तरह
जस्ट आपने क्या किया कि मूवी में एक बार
जस क्लिक किया एंटर किया सब कुछ आपने बूम
नॉट
पॉसिबल कुंडू जी स्किल तो बहुत सारी चाहिए
आपको अपडेट रहना पड़ेगा चलो आपको एक अच्छी
जगह बताता हूं चलो आपको अगर आपको पेन
टेस्टिंग
में अपडेट रहना है कि लेटेस्ट ट्रेंड और
लेटेस्ट टेक्निक्स कौन सी यूज की जाती है
और हैकर्स जो ग्रुप्स हैं वो कौन-कौन से
टूल्स लेटेस्ट यूज कर रहे हैं कौन सी
टेक्निक और कौन सी एक्सप्लोइट का यूज किया
उन्होंने एक जगह है जो शायद इवन हर एक
एथिकल हैकर्स को तो पक्का पता होना चाहिए
क्योंकि डिफेंसिव साइड वाले इसको यूज करते
हैं कभी आपने सुना होगा माइटर अटैक
फ्रेमवर्क सुना है माइटर
अटैक यह रहा यह रहा माइट टक फ्रेमवर्क
इससे परफेक्ट जगह हो नहीं सकती यह देखिए
रिकस के लिए क्याक किस तरह की टेक्निक यूज
करते हैं देखिए रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट के लिए
क्याक यूज कर यह लेटेस्ट अभी जो ट्रेंड चल
रहे हैं इनिशियल एक्सेस कैसे लिया
एग्जीक्यूशन क्लाउड पर कैसे किया
परसिस्टेंस कैसे करते हैं प्रिज एलेशन
देखिए यह एब्यूज एलिवेशन मैकेनिज्म बूट
लगन
डोमेन लट ऑफ हाई जक एग्जीक्यूशन टेक
प्रोसेस इंजेक्शन अ इस पर क्लिक किया
मैंने अरेंज हुआ है अय
देखो अभी इसका एक एटी नाम हो एक ग्रुप
होगा य प्रोसेस इंजेक्शन कितने टेकनी यूज
की गई है यह देखिए यहां पर इलेक्ट्रिक
पावर हाउस यह देखो अभी एबी के एजेंट
टेस्ला आर ये आईडी इनकी ज पर क्लिक किया
इसका डिस्क्रिप्शन है तो यहां पर आपको हर
चीज देखने को मिलेगी देखिए एंपायर देखिए
एंपायर इ कंटेंस मल्टीपल मॉड्यूल फ
इंजेक्टिंग प्रोसेस देखिए अभी मैं इस पर
क्लिक
किया इन्होने इसका यूज किया इंटर ब्यूज
एलिवेटेड कंट्रोल एक्से बायपास यूजर
एक्सेस कंट्रोल इन्होंने किया देखिए कैसे
किया इन्होने लिखा हुआ है तो बहुत कुछ
इसके अंदर देखो इंटरप्राइज के लिए आपको
देखना है मैट्रिक्स यरी प्लीज एलेशन कैसे
किया डिफेंसिव विजन कैसे किया इन्होंने अब
टेक्टिस ये रहा टेक्निक्स
डिफेंसिव ग्रुप्स आप ग्रुप्स देख सकते हो
देखो यह कौन सा ग्रुप है नेम जैसे यह रहा
अकीरा ग्रुप इनके सबके अपने टेक्निक्स
टैक्टिक्स है ये किस-किस को टारगेट करते
हैं और यहां ये क्या है थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस
के अंदर आता है आपका जो थ्रेड हंटिंग और
थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस होती है ना तो वो यहां
से रेफरेंस ली जाती है देखिए एडमिन द 38
इज अ चाइना बेस साइबर थ्रेड ग्रुप इट जज
प्रीवियसली यूज्ड न्यू वर्थी इवेंट्स लि
सन सो अब इस पर क्लिक करोगे इसके बारे में
आप इंफॉर्मेशन ले सकते हो किस टाइप का
अटैक करते हैं यह यह देखो एक्टर यूज द
फॉलोइंग कमांड एक्सप्लोइट एन देखो लो बाल
स् मालवे टू नमरे यूजर अकाउंट नेट यूजर
जस्ट आ सिंपल कमांड्स
यह नॉर्मल प्र स तो यही कमांड यूज करते हो
बट टैक्टिक्स टेक्निक्स अलग होती है यह
देखो क्लाइंट एशन फाइल एंड डिलीवरी
डिस्कवरी देखिए सी डायरेक्टरी डाउनलोड
डायरेक्टरी टेंप फाइल के अंदर इन्होने
किया तो यह रहा आपको कौन से सॉफ्टवेयर यूज
किए क्या इन्होंने यूज किया आपको यहां पर
अगर आपने रेफरेंस ले लिया और जिसको अगर
आपने समझ में आ गया कि कैसे टक्टिक
टेक्निक्स ग्रुप के बेस पर इसको डिवाइड
किया गया है और कौन ककन सी टेक्निक्स
टूल्स
और जगह का यूज कर रहे हैं य काफी अच्छे से
अरेंज किया हु देखो अभी मैंने स्टार्टिंग
में दिखाया था आपको यह देखो तोय सारी
चीजें आप एक बार पढ़ना आप सीख गए यहां से
रेफरेंस लेना तो आप अपने आप कोई भी अटैक
बहुत ही आसानी से परफॉर्म कर सकते हो समझ
में आया मैं इसको लिंक देता आपको इसको एक
बार गो थ्रू कीजिए आप आप बिगनर है ना आपके
लिए
तो हां बिल्कुल बिगनर के लिए तो सबसे
बेस्ट है
य यहां से एक्चुअल नॉलेज मिलती है आपको
आपको अगर लग रहा होगा कोई भी आपको पढ़ा
रहा है तो
आपको अच्छे से नहीं पढ़ा र बोल रहा होगे
नहीं अच्छी इंफॉर्मेशन दे यहां से आप
क्रॉस चेक कर सकते हो कितने लोग यहां से
लेवल की आपको पढ़ाते हैं समझ रहे हो
क्योंकि दज आर एक्चुअल यूज्ड बाय द शोक
एनालिस्ट माइट अटैक जानामाना फ्रेमवर्क
ऐसे बहुत सारे
हैं एनी वन किसी और कोई सवाल और कुछ मुझसे
पूछना चाहता है
आप किसी कोई और सवाल
नेक्स्ट क्लास आपकी होगी इसी में लिनक्स
प्लीज एस्केलेशन मे भी लिनक्स कर्नल
एक्सप्लोइट्स आपको हिंट कर रहा हूं या
एक्सप्लोइटिंग क्रोन जॉब्स इनमें से एक
क्लास होगी दो में से
एपीटीपी दे आर लॉट ऑफ ग्रुप्स जो बेसिकली
क्या होता है कि जब माइट अटैक फ्रेमवर्क
ने क्या किया पहले कुछ टाइम पहले बहुत
सालों पहले ऐसा कोई डेटाबेस अवेलेबल नहीं
था इन्होंने क्या किया अकॉर्डिंग टू द
साइबर अटैक्स जो एंटरप्राइज प हुए हैं या
आपके कंट्री टू कंट्री जो साइबर अटैक्स
हुए हैं उनका डाटा कलेक्ट किया
उनकी स्ट्रेटजी को पढ़ा सब पर थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस उनका शोक का डाटा पढ़ा थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस की थ्रेट हंटिंग की तो उसके
बेस पर क्या कि बहुत सारी पॉलिसीज भी पास
हुई उसके बेस पर बहुत सारे डाटा मिले तो
उनको कलेक्ट कर करके उनकी मेथोड जीी
उन्होंने क्या मैथोलॉजी यूज की किस टूल का
यूज किया कहां पर उन्होंने क्या मालवे
इंजेक्ट किया किस टेक्निक को यूज किया ओके
उसके बेस पर धीरे-धीरे उन्होंने क्या कर
दिया कि वो ग्रुप बना दिए
एपीटीसी प्रसन थ्रेट बोल रहे हो आप वो
छोटे-छोटे ग्रुप बना मतलब छोटे नहीं बहुत
बड़े ग्रुप अपने आप में क्योंकि और उनका
स्पेसिफिक है कि उन्होंने आर्थिक जितने भी
अटैक्स परफॉर्म किए हैं तो वह
अटैक्स वो किस कंट्री पे ही करते हैं या
पर्टिकुलर किस ग्रुप पे वह करते हैं तो
वहां से वोह रेफरेंस लिया जाता है उसी के
बेस पर डाटा एक तैयार किया गया उस डाटा पे
क्या किया कि हर एक ग्रुप को डिवाइड किया
अभी यहां पर क्या होता है टीटीपी आपने
सुना होगा टी टूल्स टैक्टिक्स और टेक्निक
एक टर्मिनोलॉजी होती है इसके अंदर भी तो
इट इज वेरी इंपोर्टेंट फॉर एनी थ्रेड
किसी भी थड हंटर के लिए काफी इंपोर्टेंट
होता है यह कि अगर किसी को अगर टीटीपी हो
गया उसके बाद आप
एक कुछ चीज होते पूरा एक मतलब शक की अगर
जनी पर चलोगे ना काफी इंटरेस्टिंग है
और मुझे एटली डोंट रिमेंबर की नाउ एक्ली ट
कुछ एक ट्रायंगल होती है टवी से च
ट्रायंगल आई डोंट नो रिमेंबर तो उसको हम
यूज कर करते हैंब भी हम थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस
करते हैं तो देखो जितना एजी मतलब अभी कोई
भी अटैकर्स है अटैक करने वाला आप सोचिए या
मेरे मैं भी कहीं से पढ़ा हूं मैं भी किसी
की मैथोलॉजी फॉलो कर रहा हूंगा मैं भी
कहीं से पढ़ा हूं या मैंने भी कहीं से
पढ़ा है और स्टार्टिंग में जब मैं सीखता
हूं तो किसी के स्टेप ही कॉपी करूंगा ना
जैसे कि आप लोग मुझसे सीख रहे हो तो आप
सडन कभी भी आप डायरेक्टली कभी भी नहीं आप
अपने स्टेप्स क्रिएट नहीं करते डायरेक्टली
जिससे पढ़ के आते हो आपके दिमाग में वही
रहते हो और वही स्टेप आप फॉलो करते हो तो
उसके बाद जैसे आपको एक्सपीरियंस होगा जैसे
जैसे आपको चीजें समझ में आएंगी आप फ खुद
के स्टेप्स बनाते हो अकॉर्डिंग टू
रिक्वायरमेंट यही चीज होती है जितना
मुश्किल आपके लिए अटैक करना है या जितना
मुश्किल किसी के लिए डिफेंड करना है उतना
ही मुश्किल अटैक भी करना है अग रियलिस्टिक
अटैक करना है रियलिस्टिक अटैक करने के लिए
आपको सच में डोमेन की जरूरत होगी सच में
ईमेल सर्वर की जरूरत होगी अगर
अटैक को रियलिस्टिक बनाना है
ओके सर अमित 255 स्पैमिंग इन द ग्रुप अगर
आपको विंडो डिलीट करके कालिस ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम डाउनलोड करना तो कर
लीजिए एक पेन ड्राइव को बूटेबल बनाइए
विंडोज को फैक्ट्री सेट कीजिए कंपलीटली
डिलीट कीजिए देन उसके बाद इंस्टॉल कर
लीजिए हो
जाएगा अगर आप खुद से नहीं हो पा रहा हो तो
किसी से करवा
लीजिए अभी आपके लिए मैं अपना विंडो डिलीट
करके आपके लिए मैं नक् तो इंस्टॉल करके
नहीं दिखा सकता ना
ब्रो क्यों मेरे विंडो से बहुत सारा काम
रहता है मेरे पास सिंपल एक ही मशीन है और
किसी और कोई
सवाल शुभम ये बहुत बड़ा टॉपिक है
टेक्निक्स टैक्टिक्स और प्रोसीजर शॉक
एनालिस का अपने आप में एक पॉपुलर टॉपिक है
ये कोई और किसी का कोई
सवाल किसी का कोई सवाल नहीं है तो हम सेशन
को एंड कर सकते हैं
बेस्ट ओस फॉर द हैकिंग इज द लिनक्स
नक्स इज द बेस्ट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम और इन द
सेंस अगर टोटली एनोनिमस ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
यूज करना है तो एंड क्यूब क्यूब ओस एंड
टेल ओस इ द बेस्ट एंड बेस्ट एंड बेस्ट
बिकॉज वो टोर चेन का यूज करते हैं बट उन
इन दैट केस उसके लिए आपको उनको यूज करना
आना चाहिए और फिर उसके लिए आपको पेशेंस भी
चाहिए क्योंकि टोर में आपका जो नेटवर्क
स्लो चलेगा बहुत जगह आपको ब्लॉकेज मिलेगा
यह होती है कई आईएसपी आपको अलाव नहीं
करेंगी आपको रिजल्ट स्लो मिलेंगे और वह
आपने पेशेंस बहुत हाई लेवल होना चाहिए
आपको रियलिस्टिक अटैक करना है और आपको
पूरी तरह हाईलाइट हाइड करना अपने आपको को
तो आपको अच्छे से को अपने मालवेयर कोफ
स्केट करना आना चाहिए कोड करना आना चाहिए
डिकोड भी करना आना चाहिए देन उसके बाद
आपका जो स्ट्रंग
चेंज होता रहना चाहिए बाद में और
रियलिस्टिक करने के लिए हर चीज आपकी
परफेक्ट होनी चाहिए तो दिस इज अ
वेरी डिफरेंट
थिंग लेकिन नक् के बगैर कुछ नहीं क्योंकि
वो भी सारी लिनक्स ही है बट उनका काम करने
का तरीका अलग है जैसे टेल ओस का आपको मैं
बताता हूं जस्ट इतना ही है कि आप किसी पेन
ड्राइव को बूटेबल टेल ओस बनाइए क्योंकि वो
वर्चुल बॉक्स में नहीं चलता चलता है बट
फायदा नहीं उसको यूज करने का टेलर्स को
डायरेक्टली बूटेबल पड बनाओगे उसको यूज
करोगे तो उसका क्या जैसे आपने टक परफॉर्म
किया और पेन ड्राइव को हटा दिया तो जितने
भी ट्रेसेस थे आपके मशीन में कोई ट्रेसेस
नहीं होगा लेकिन उसने जो भी कुछ काम किया
सारे ट्रेसेस क्या हो जाएंगे डिलीट हो
जाएंगे
मतलब नो ट्रेसेस ऑफ द अटैक्स अटैक के लिए
कोई भी ट्रेस नहीं
रहेगा आपने अटैक किया बूटेबल पेनड्राइव
बना के बट आपको ध्यान रखना है कि टेल ओस
के केस में उस पेन ड्राइव को कि
परसिस्टेंट नहीं बनाना है परसिस्टेंट बना
लिया तो प्रॉब्लम हो जाएगी क्योंकि अगर
आपने पेन ड्राइव निकाली अटैक करके और कहीं
पर फेंक दिया डर के मारे तो उस पन ड्रा
में ट्रेस र जाएंगे और अदर वाइज आपने क्या
किया टेल को यूज किया परसिस्टेंट नहीं है
टो चन को सेट अप किया अटैक परफॉर्म किया
और पेन ड्राइव को निकाला और फेंक दिया तो
पेनड्राइव किसी के हाथ में लग भी जाएगी तो
को ट्रेसेस नहीं
मिलेंगे और क्यूबस का सिस्टम और भी अलग है
क्यूबस में क्या होता है
इससे भी ज्यादा और सिक्योर है क्योंकि
उसमें भी टोर का यूज किया जाता है बट
उसमें क्या होता है कि रम और हार्ड डिस्क
का सब अपने आप में आइसोलेटेड है एवरीथिंग
इज आइसोलेटेड
मम और हार्डवेयर यह सब आइसोलेटेड
है तो इट इज वेरी
इंटरेस्टिंग किसी के ट्रेसेस किसी के ऊपर
नहीं
रहते और तो यही दो मोस्ट पॉपुलर ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम्स है
जो हाई लेवल अटैक्स पर यूज किए जाते हैं
सीसी जीएसपी एक बेसिक लेवल का है बिल्कुल
ही फंडामेंटल आपको बिल्कुल आप बोल सकते हो
कि आपको कमटी सिक्योरिटी प्लस सुना है
किसी ने नाम पटेल कमटी सिक्योरिटी प्लस का
नाम सुना
है किसी ने भी कमटी सिक्योरिटी प्लस का
नाम सुना है हां तो कमटिया सिक्योरिटी
प्लस समझिए आपको बकल फंडामेंटल जानने हैं
कि साइबर सिक्योरिटी के बिल्कुल
हैकिंग बिल्कुल फंडामेंटल्स
तो आप डीसी जेएसपी जो है उसको परचेज कर
सकते हो और पढ़ सकते हो बट डीए उससे
एडवांस कितने लॉजिक की बात है बोला सर कि
एक डीसी जेएचपी बिल्कुल फंडामेंटल लेवल का
है वह पेड है उसके बाद एक मिड लेवल का
फ्री
है समझ रहे हो
मतलब आपके क्वेश्चन का आंसर यह है कि आपको
क्या करना है पहले तो आप मुझे नहीं पता कि
आपको कितनी नॉलेज है आपको अगर अच्छी नॉलेज
है तो आपको स्टेप बाय स्टेप जाना है स्टेप
बाय स्टेप मतलब अच्छे से इंफॉर्मेशन
इकट्ठा कीजिए उसके बाद आप चाहे निकटो का
यूज किए नलि का यूज कीजिए जो मोस्ट पॉपुलर
टूल्स है
देन डोमेन के अंदर वनटी फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश कीजिए
ओके क्योंकि बेसिक लेवल के स्टेप्स वही है
एन मैप का भी यूज कर सकते हो और उसके लिए
आपके पास एटलीस्ट स्टेप्स उस नॉलेज होने
चाहिए और आप बिल्कुल ही फ्रेश ही हो आपके
पास कोई स्टेप्स नॉलेज नहीं है तो हां
क्लाउड फ्लेर तो बिल्कुल ब्लॉक करेगा
तो फर्द उसके और भी डोमेन ढूंढ है ना
बिल्कुल एक ही डोमेन
है ओके फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं तो काफी
टाइम हो
गया तो बाय बाय
एंड थैंक यू
सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन ठीक है तो अगले
सेशन में मिलते हैं तो आप मतलब मेरे को
लिंकन प वो कीजिए एक बार टैग ओके तो मैं
आपको उसमें आंसर प्रोवाइड कर दूंगा मतलब
थोड़े बहुत स्टेप्स आपको बता दूंगा ओके तो
बाय बाय
एंड थैंक
यू नेक्स्ट मिलते हैं क्लास में ओके बाय
बाय टेक केयर गुड नाइट